Well, you know, we both use Airbnb on so many trips, so many great family memories. While you're away, your home could be an Airbnb. Every time you're out of town, have you thought about your own place just sitting there empty and about what do other people do with their homes when traveling or vacationing? It would be the perfect time to host your property on Airbnb. I used to think of Airbnb mostly as a way to travel, but once I thought about all the people hosting, it changed the way I think about Airbnb. And if you're traveling a bunch, you could host your home on Airbnb while you're away. Seriously, you might not even realize what a great opportunity
嗯，你知道，我们俩在很多旅行中都用过Airbnb，留下了很多美好的家庭回忆。当你外出时，你的家可以成为Airbnb。每次你出城时，有没有想过你自己的房子就那样空着，或者想过别人在旅行或度假时是怎么处理他们的房子的？现在正是把你的房产放在Airbnb上出租的最佳时机。我过去主要把Airbnb看作一种旅行方式，但当我想到所有那些房东时，我对Airbnb的看法就改变了。如果你经常旅行，你可以在外出时把你的家放在Airbnb上出租。说真的，你可能甚至没有意识到这是一个多么好的机会。
that is. If you travel often, or if you've got a guest room that just sits empty, or maybe a vacation home that's only used a few months a year, you could be making money by hosting a great way to fund your next trip. If you've ever thought about opening your doors, now's the time. Hosting on Airbnb is easier than you think, and it's such a cool way to share your space and your community with the world. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.com slash host. Hello there, and welcome to our second drink of money part two. This episode might go down in office ladies' lore for two tangents that people still mention to us to this day as their favorites. 100 percent. Here's what they are. First, Jenna, you have your amazing pockets and panty line speech. It's epic. People freaking loved it. I don't want to spoil this if you haven't heard the episode, but you're going to love it. Yes. And then, Angela, you go on a hilarious John Wick rant. We even have video of it because we were zooming back then. We play this video in our live show. Office ladies, folks, you know what I'm talking about. I can't.
如果你经常旅行，或者你有一个空置的客房，又或者是一个一年只用几个月的度假屋，你可以通过出租来赚钱，这可是资助你下一次旅行的好方法。如果你曾经想过敞开大门，现在就是时候了。在Airbnb上出租比你想象的要容易，这是一种与世界分享你的空间和社区的超酷方式。你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。请访问Airbnb.ca.com/host了解详情。大家好，欢迎来到我们的《金钱》第二部分。这一集可能会载入《办公室》姐妹的史册，因为其中有两个片段至今仍被人们津津乐道，称之为最爱。百分之百。它们是这样的。首先，珍娜，你有那段关于口袋和内裤痕迹的精彩演讲。太经典了。大家简直爱死它了。如果你还没听过这一集，我不想剧透，但你一定会喜欢的。是的。然后，安吉拉，你进行了一段关于《疾速追杀》的搞笑咆哮。我们甚至有视频，因为那时我们还在用Zoom。我们在现场演出中播放了这个视频。《办公室》的粉丝们，你们知道我在说什么。我不行了。
I cannot believe that pockets and panty lines and your John Wick rant are both in this episode. I know. What was happening on this day? Like, we were, my gosh. It was the pandemic. We were in our closets. I was in a closet in Santa Fe. Oh, that's right.
我简直不敢相信口袋、内裤痕迹和你的《疾速追杀》咆哮都在这一集里。我知道。那天到底发生了什么？天哪，我们当时在壁橱里。我当时在圣达菲的一个壁橱里。哦，没错。
We had relocated to Santa Fe, and I was in this balkin closet. Well, there was something in the air because we really both have a moment. Well, Angela, I actually found something about. our John Wick conversation. Something that might change everything. I'm going to save it, because if anyone has not heard this episode yet, I want them to enjoy it today. But just know, for our next Friday chit chat, I am bringing this back up. Oh, no. Okay. Okay. I have something to share. Oh, sure. Okay. All right. Dun, done, done. Well, let's get to some of our tidbits. I'm going to start with a fun background catch from Allison in Madison, Wisconsin.
我们搬到了圣达菲，我当时就在那个步入式衣橱里。好吧，当时气氛确实有点不对劲，因为我们俩确实都有点情绪失控。好吧，安吉拉，我其实发现了一些关于我们《疾速追杀》对话的事情。一些可能会改变一切的事情。我要先留着，因为如果有人还没听过这一集，我希望他们今天能好好享受。但请记住，在下周五的闲聊中，我会再次提起这件事。哦，不。好吧。好吧。我有东西要分享。哦，当然。好吧。好吧。当当当。好了，让我们进入一些花絮。我要从威斯康星州麦迪逊市的艾莉森发来的一个有趣的背景发现开始。
So we didn't talk about this the first time we broke down this episode. And Allison said, if you go to 12 minutes and 58 seconds, as Jim and Pam are reading off their reviews, you will see a wooden shelf that displays several of Dwight's samurai swords, but it also has six of his Dundees. Oh. Yeah, they're like all lined up in a row. I went to this time code. And it's pretty amazing.
所以我们第一次拆解这一集时没有谈到这个。艾莉森说，如果你看到12分58秒，当吉姆和帕姆在读他们的评论时，你会看到一个木架，上面展示着德怀特的几把武士刀，但上面还有六个他的邓迪奖杯。哦。是的，它们就像排成一排一样。我看了那个时间点。这真是太神奇了。
Dwight has six Dundies. Are you able to read what any of them are for? No, you can't. I wish. So this happened to me when I was trying to zoom in on Michael's Dundies in dinner party. It just, it gets so like pixelated or something. You can't read them. Because you know Phil Shea made sure they each had something.
德怀特有六个邓迪奖杯。你能读出它们是颁给什么的吗？不，读不出来。我真希望可以。这就像我试图放大《晚宴》那一集中迈克尔的邓迪奖杯时发生的情况一样。它变得太像素化了，根本读不出来。因为你知道菲尔·谢肯定确保了每一个奖杯都有对应的奖项。
Exactly. Well, Jenna, there's one other thing I want to point out. So in our first rewatch, we briefly discussed the reviews that Jim and Pam leave on TripAdvisor about Shrewp Farms. And one of them was the natural aroma of the beats drifts into the bedroom and makes you dream of simpler times. Yes, my personal favorite was tablemaking never seemed so possible. Well, guess what? There were so, so many more in the candy bag alts and they were cracking me up.
没错。好吧，珍娜，还有一件事我想指出。在我们的第一次重温中，我们简要讨论了吉姆和帕姆在猫途鹰上对施鲁特农场的评论。其中一个是“甜菜的天然香气飘进卧室，让你梦回更简单的时代”。是的，我个人最喜欢的是“做桌子看起来从未如此简单”。好吧，你猜怎么着？在糖果袋里还有很多很多，它们让我笑得停不下来。
I'm really curious if you remember doing a bunch of these. I want to read you four. Okay. Number one, you will be reminded of your grandparents for some reason. Okay. I do not remember those. Number two, largest VHS collection in western Pennsylvania. Amazing.
我真的很好奇你是否记得写过这些。我想读给你听四个。好的。第一，你会因为某种原因想起你的祖父母。好的。我不记得那些了。第二，宾夕法尼亚州西部最大的VHS录像带收藏。太棒了。
Number three, manure distribution class really exists. Really. Wow. And the last one, staff available 24-7. I mean, that sounds positive. That does. All right. Well, we also got a fan mill flurry about the Dwight and Jim scene in the stairwell.
第三，粪便分配课真的存在。真的吗？哇。最后一个，员工24小时全天候待命。我的意思是，这听起来很正面。确实是。好了，我们还收到了一大堆关于楼梯间里德怀特和吉姆那场戏的粉丝来信。
This is when Dwight is so sad and Jim has gone to comfort him. Right. And when we first watched the scene, I'd said, I thought Jim didn't do a good enough job. I remember. We felt like Jim only pointed out the negative stuff. He didn't like truly pep Dwight up. Right. Well, guess what? What? Many people disagreed with us. Disagree. Oh yeah. Alyssa R wrote in and said, I have some thoughts on why what Jim said to Dwight was absolutely perfect. By telling Dwight how he felt when he was in a similar situation, Jim was validating Dwight's feelings in a way. he would accept. He didn't downplay how Dwight was feeling or say that Dwight would get through it. He just empathized with Dwight. It was one of my favorite scenes because Jim really cares about
这是德怀特非常难过，吉姆去安慰他的时候。对。当我们第一次看这场戏时，我说过，我觉得吉姆做得不够好。我记得。我们觉得吉姆只是指出了负面东西。他没有真正地鼓励德怀特。对。好吧，你猜怎么着？什么？很多人不同意我们的看法。不同意。哦，是的。艾丽莎·R写信说，对于吉姆对德怀特说的话为什么绝对完美，我有一些想法。通过告诉德怀特他在类似情况下的感受，吉姆以一种德怀特能接受的方式认可了德怀特的感受。他没有淡化德怀特的感受，也没有说德怀特会挺过去的。他只是与德怀特产生了共鸣。这是我最喜欢的场景之一，因为吉姆真的很关心
Dwight and it shows how much Jim has grown over the past three seasons. Season one, Jim would not have done that. I like that. I thought that was a good observation. I really like that take on it. Yeah. All right. I stand corrected. I know, me too. And then we also mentioned that there were a lot of extra deleted scenes between Oscar and Michael, as you know, Oscar is trying to help Michael with this financial mess. There is one scene we didn't talk about that cracked me up. We find out how Michael has been investing his money over the years. Lady, for years, he has been investing. Oh my gosh, what is it? Let's hear it. Okay, you need to focus, Michael. You need to stop spending money. Yeah. Well, I hate to ask you this, but are there any...
德怀特，这显示了吉姆在过去三季中成长了多少。第一季的吉姆是不会那样做的。我喜欢这个。我觉得这是一个很好的观察。我真的很喜欢这个观点。是的。好吧。我收回我的话。我知道，我也是。然后我们还提到，奥斯卡和迈克尔之间有很多额外的删减片段，如你所知，奥斯卡正试图帮助迈克尔处理财务混乱。有一个我们没谈到的场景让我笑得前仰后合。我们发现迈克尔多年来是如何投资他的钱的。天哪，多年来他一直在投资。哦，天哪，是什么？让我们听听。好的，你需要集中注意力，迈克尔。你需要停止花钱。是的。好吧，我不想问你这个，但有什么...
retirement funds you can borrow from my CDs you have CDs okay okay we're back my CDs are in a portfolio a rather large portfolio called case logic and the case logic portfolio is currently in the backseat of my car there is another smaller case logic portfolio clipped to my visor what I'm asking about certificates of deposit. I've been putting money into CDs for years. I bought music that I didn't even like. Wow.
你可以借钱的退休基金吗？我的CD，你有CD？好的，好的，我们回来了。我的CD在一个文件夹里，一个相当大的文件夹，叫Case Logic，而那个Case Logic文件夹目前在我车的后座上。我的遮阳板上还夹着另一个较小的Case Logic文件夹。我问的是大额存单。我多年来一直把钱存进CD里。我买了连我自己都不喜欢的音乐。哇。
By the way, the minute he said case logic, Sam started cracking up. It's so good. It's so good. We all had those big case logic things for our CDs. Oh, my gosh. Oh, well, those were some good tidbits, lady. I liked them. Thanks. Well, now, here is our second drink of Money Part 2.
顺便说一句，他一说Case Logic，萨姆就开始大笑。太棒了。太棒了。我们都有那些装CD的大Case Logic文件夹。哦，天哪。哦，好吧，这些是一些很好的花絮，女士。我很喜欢。谢谢。好了，现在，这是我们的《金钱》第二部分。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello. Hello. Hi, everyone. It is Money Part 2 today. Second half of money. Second half of money, we got lots to cover. It's season 4, episode 8, written by Paul Lieberstein, directed by Paul Lieberstein. Angela, I'm coming in hot today and I'm coming in right with a summary. Are you ready? Yeah. No banter. No banter at the top. Okay. Here we go. All right. In Money Part 1, we found out that Michael has money trouble. He had to take a second job as a telemarketer. Meanwhile, Pam and Jim visited Shrewt Farms, which Dwight has started operating as a bed and breakfast. And Andy serenated Angela in hopes of winning her heart.
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》姐妹。你好。你好。大家好。今天是《金钱》第二部分。金钱的后半部分。金钱的后半部分，我们要讲的内容很多。这是第四季第八集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，保罗·利伯斯坦导演。安吉拉，我今天状态火热，我直接进入总结。你准备好了吗？是的。没有闲聊。开头没有闲聊。好的。我们开始吧。好的。在《金钱》第一部分中，我们发现迈克尔有经济困难。他不得不找了一份电话推销员的兼职。与此同时，帕姆和吉姆参观了施鲁特农场，德怀特已经把它作为民宿开始经营了。安迪为安吉拉唱小夜曲，希望能赢得她的芳心。
Well, this week, Michael works with Oscar to try and get himself out of debt. Andy continues to pursue Angela and Kelly flunts her new relationship with Daryl in front of Ryan, who really just wants everyone in the office to use PowerPoint. PowerPoint, PowerPoint, PowerPoint. Michael just thinks it's like a cheer from cheerleading camp. He's literally powerfully pointing his finger as he says at it. Yep. All right.
好吧，这周，迈克尔和奥斯卡一起工作，试图让自己摆脱债务。安迪继续追求安吉拉，凯利在瑞安面前炫耀她与达里尔的新恋情，而瑞安其实只是想让办公室里的每个人都使用PowerPoint。PowerPoint，PowerPoint，PowerPoint。迈克尔只是觉得这就像啦啦队训练营里的口号。他说的时候，手指真的在有力地指着。是的。好的。
Well, fast fact number one, we mentioned last week that this was the first episode that was directed by Paul Lieberstein. But I discovered in my research this week, Angela, that he was nominated for an Emmy Award for directing this episode. His first episode. Wow. Where do you go from there? You're like, I crushed it. I'm done. Yeah, pretty much.
好吧，第一个快速事实，我们上周提到这是保罗·利伯斯坦导演的第一集。但我这周在研究中发现，安吉拉，他因为导演这一集被提名艾美奖。他的第一集。哇。从那以后你还能去哪儿？你会觉得，我太棒了。我完成了。是的，差不多。
Well, here's something crazy. He was up against Paul Feig, who was nominated for directing the season four finale Good by Toby, but they both lost. Aw. To Barry Sonenfeld for pushing daisies. Oh. I mean, Barry is a fantastic director. I know.
好吧，这里有一件疯狂的事。他当时和保罗·费格竞争，保罗·费格因为导演第四季大结局《再见托比》被提名，但他们都输了。噢。输给了《冥侦探艾莉》的巴里·索南菲尔德。哦。我的意思是，巴里是一位出色的导演。我知道。
Well, dang it. We had a Paul versus Paul. Yes. Who would have won? I would have been able to choose between those two guys. Yes, maybe better. Maybe better, you know, for our sake, because it's about us. Maybe better.
好吧，该死。我们经历了一场保罗对保罗的竞争。是的。谁会赢呢？我本来可以在那两个家伙之间做出选择。是的，也许更好。也许更好，你知道，为了我们，因为这是关于我们的。也许更好。
You know why? Because you know Rain would have made fun of the loser Paul. It would have been winner Paul and loser Paul. You know Rain would have done that. You're so right. All right, lady, fast fact number two. This episode introduces the relationship between Kelly and Daryl. And I have to tell you, this was a very popular storyline.
你知道为什么吗？因为你知道雷恩会嘲笑输掉的那个保罗。那会是赢家保罗和输家保罗。你知道雷恩会那样做的。你说得太对了。好的，女士，第二个快速事实。这一集介绍了凯利和达里尔的关系。我必须告诉你，这是一个非常受欢迎的故事情节。
with fans. Oh, people loved this. Loved it. I love it. Me too. I love how like no nonsense Daryl is and it spirals Kelly out. She does not know how to handle his just direct, honest, no game playing. Yeah. Well, it started a number of debates online. There was Kelly and Daryl versus Kelly and Ryan. There was a very short-lived Carol. Carol. Carol mashup of Kelly and Daryl. Carol with a K. People made jokes who will last longer Carol or Carol. If you remember Michael's girlfriend, Carol. Oh. Yes. So this was just really, really fun to see this relationship play out. It was mostly like a revenge date, I think, on Kelly's part. But she also think? You think? I mean, she literally, Daryl has a whole talking head where he says, you know, I get
粉丝们很喜欢。哦，人们喜欢这个。喜欢它。我也喜欢。我喜欢达里尔那种不废话的风格，这让凯利抓狂。她不知道如何应对他那种直接、诚实、不玩游戏的态度。是的。好吧，它在网上引发了许多争论。有凯利和达里尔对阵凯利和瑞安。还有一个非常短命的卡罗尔。卡罗尔。凯利和达里尔的混合体卡罗尔。带K的卡罗尔。人们开玩笑说谁会持续更久，卡罗尔还是卡罗尔。如果你还记得迈克尔的女朋友卡罗尔的话。哦。是的，所以看到这段关系的发展真的非常非常有趣。我想这在凯利看来主要是一次报复性的约会。但她也觉得？你觉得吗？我的意思是，她真的，达里尔有一个完整的独白，他说，你知道，我
excited when I see the little dude come in the office because that's when she pays attention to me. But she also does seem like a little taken with him. But guys, the thing about this, and a lot of people pointed this out online, is like, finally there's a man who's treating her well and she can't deal. Like, she is attracted to the drama. She is attracted to Ryan. Ryan is as well. This is their downfall. We will see it play out over several seasons. Well, we all know couples like this. Come on. You have that friend who was always attracted to the guy that made her a total mess, right? Yeah.
看到那个小家伙走进办公室时我很兴奋，因为那时她才会关注我。但她看起来也确实对他有点着迷。但是伙计们，关于这件事，很多人在网上指出了这一点，就是终于有一个男人在好好对待她，而她却无法应对。就像，她被戏剧性吸引。她被瑞安吸引。瑞安也是如此。这是他们的垮台。我们将看到它在几季中上演。好吧，我们都知道这样的情侣。得了吧。你有一个朋友总是被那个让她变得一团糟的家伙吸引，对吧？是的。
And vice versa, right? Dudes as well. Yeah. And you'd be like, what about that other person who's so incredibly nice to you? And they're like, no, I want the person that makes me crazy. Yeah, pretty much. Well, there are great Kelly and Daryl scenes in this episode, but there was a deleted one. I loved.
反之亦然，对吧？男人们也是。是的。你会说，那个对你那么好的人怎么样？他们会说，不，我想要那个让我疯狂的人。是的，差不多。好吧，这一集里有很棒的凯利和达里尔的场景，但有一个删减片段。我很喜欢。
It happens towards the end, but it's, I'll wait until we get there, but it's Kelly trying to make amends. Oh, oh, that sounds great. Oh, I can't wait for that. All right, lady, fast fact number three, I don't know if you remember, Angela, but right around the time that we were filming this episode, Steve Carell won Best TV Actor at the Teen Choice Awards. No, I didn't remember that. Well, you know, you win a surfboard. That's the award. That's the award statue is a giant colorful surfboard. Now, Steve had won a Golden Globe. Yeah. And we had won the SAG Award. But this was different. Our show had won an Emmy. Our show had won an Emmy.
它发生在结尾处，但我会等到我们讲到那里再说，但那是凯利试图弥补。哦，哦，听起来很棒。哦，我等不及了。好的，女士，第三个快速事实，我不知道你是否记得，安吉拉，就在我们拍摄这一集的时候，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在青少年选择奖上获得了最佳电视男演员奖。不，我不记得了。好吧，你知道，你赢得的是一块冲浪板。那是奖项。那个奖杯是一个巨大的彩色冲浪板。现在，史蒂夫赢得了金球奖。是的。我们赢得了演员工会奖。但这不同。我们的节目赢得了艾美奖。我们的节目赢得了艾美奖。
But this was like you've hit the mainstream. This was a big deal. To give you some context, here are the previous winners in Steve's category in the years prior. Matt LeBlanc for Friends, Ashton Coucher, Wilmer Volderama for that 70s show. Then Steve won. After that, the Jonas Brothers won. I'm telling you, this was like Steve is a bona fide star. He's a star.
但这就像你已经进入了主流。这是一件大事。为了给你一些背景，这是史蒂夫在之前几年里他那个类别的往届获奖者。马特·勒布朗（《老友记》），阿什顿·库彻，威尔默·瓦尔德拉马（《70年代秀》）。然后史蒂夫赢了。在那之后，乔纳斯兄弟赢了。我告诉你，这就像史蒂夫是一个真正的明星。他是一个明星。
I mean, if the teens are voting for you, come on. Yes. Well, I kind of noticed, Angie, that I feel like right around this time for all of us on the office, this is when I feel like our lives started to change and we are about to enter what I am calling our Hollywood years. We start having the most crazy experiences. Yeah. I mean, I remember I was standing in line for this party we'd been invited to and standing. in front of me are Robert De Niro and Joe Pesci. Yeah. I'm waiting in a line with those guys to get into a party. And I remember looking at you and being like, what is happening right now? Jenna, I remember being at a party during the
我的意思是，如果青少年为你投票，得了吧。是的。好吧，我有点注意到，安吉，我觉得就在这个时候，对于我们《办公室》的所有人来说，我觉得我们的生活开始改变了，我们即将进入我所说的我们的好莱坞岁月。我们开始有最疯狂的经历。是的。我的意思是，我记得我当时排队参加我们被邀请参加的这个派对，站在我前面的是罗伯特·德尼罗和乔·佩西。是的。我和那些家伙排队进入一个派对。我记得看着你，心想，现在到底发生了什么？珍娜，我记得在颁奖典礼季节的一个派对上。布拉德·皮特在那里。哦，是的。还有安吉丽娜·朱莉。是的。还有莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。就像我不认识他，伙计们。顺便说一句，我没和他们任何人说话。不。因为我吓坏了。我和珍娜、奥斯卡还有杰克·麦克布雷尔在角落里跳舞。这就是我们做的。好吧，我只记得当时我一直在给家里打电话，告诉我的父母我们身上发生的那些疯狂的事情。这也是我们开始上脱口秀节目的时候，记得吗？那是一个全新的世界。我记得，安吉拉，你是《办公室》第一位上大卫·莱特曼节目的女演员。哦，天哪，我当时太紧张了，伙计们。我太紧张了。那天早上我拉肚子了。这真是分享过头了。我太紧张了。大卫·莱特曼非常友善，他的整个团队也是，就像他们知道我快要拉裤子了一样。我太激动了。我是他的超级粉丝，我姐姐拍了一张电视上我在莱特曼节目里的照片，我把它装在框里。就像那是互联网上什么都没有的时候，你知道吗？是的。所以她拍了一张我电视的照片。好吧，那真是
award show season. Brad Pitt was there. Oh, yeah. And Angelina Jolie. Yeah. And a Leo DiCaprio. Like I don't know him, guys. By the way, I didn't talk to any of them. No. Because I was terrified. I danced in the corner with Jenna and Oscar and Jack McBrayer. That's what we did. Well, I just remember at this time I was constantly calling home to tell my parents all the crazy stuff that was happening to us. And this was also when we started going on talk shows, remember? And that was a whole new world. I remember, Angela, you were the first female cast member of the office to go on David Letterman. Oh, my gosh, I was so nervous, you guys. I was so nervous. I had the runs that morning. is such an overshare. I was so nervous. And David Letterman was so kind and his whole team there was so, it's like they knew I was about to poop my pants or something. I was so thrilled. I was such a fan of his that my sister took a photo of the TV of me on Letterman and I have it in a frame. Like that's before anything was like on the internet, you know? Yes. So she took a picture of my TV. Well, it was just.
一段如此疯狂的时光，安吉，我非常感激能和你一起经历这一切，因为我觉得我们对这一切有同样的反应。我们被邀请感到非常高兴，我们喜欢互相八卦我们看到的一切，然后第二天我们醒来，去了塔吉特百货，买了东西做一个花环，我们的生活照旧。哦，天哪，我，是的，好吧，听着，当你觉得你是一条离开水的鱼，你回头看，你最好的朋友也是那条离开水的鱼，你知道，你会没事的。你知道，就像那个豪华厕所，就像，我记得它就像一个移动厕所，但它是我见过的最豪华的移动厕所。你和我无法释怀。我们对这个豪华移动厕所感到兴奋不已。我敢肯定人们会想，好吧，女士们。我们说，它里面有灯。是的，当他们举办这些派对时，这是一回事。他们带来了这些豪华厕所，伙计们。我们无法停止谈论它。我们拍了它的照片。
such a crazy time and ang i'm so grateful that i got to go through all of that with you because i feel like we had the same reaction to all of this we were so tickled to be invited we love to gossip with each other about everything we saw and then the next day we woke up and we went to target and we bought things to make a wreath and our lives went on exactly oh my gosh i yeah well listen when you feel like you're a fish out of water and you look over your shoulder and your best friend is that same fish out of water, you know, you're going to be okay. You know, it's like that fancy toilet that was like, I remember it was like a porta potty, but it was like the fanciest porta potty I'd ever seen. And you and I couldn't get over it. We are geeking out over this fancy porta potty. And I'm sure people were like, okay, ladies. And we're like, it's got lights inside. Yes, this is a thing when they have these parties. they bring in these fancy toilets, you guys. We couldn't stop talking about it. We took pictures of it.
我们把它剪贴下来了。哦，天哪。它有一个瓷水槽，里面还放着音乐。记得吗，不知怎么的，他们把音乐传进了这个豪华移动厕所？我从来没见过这样的东西。这就是我们记录的东西。与此同时，节目里的其他演员就像真的在和布拉德·皮特喝香槟，而我们却在拍移动厕所的照片，我们无法停止
We scrapped booked about it. Oh my gosh. It had like a porcelain sink and it has music playing in it. Remember somehow they funneled music into this fancy porta potty? I'd never seen anything like it. This was the stuff we documented. Meanwhile, like other cast members on the show are like literally toasting champagne with Brad Pitt and we're overtaking photos of the porta potty and we can't stop.
谈论它。我们说，你需要看的东西。我们今晚要写信回家的东西就是这个厕所。我和我爸爸详细谈过那个。他说，你有一个要踩的踏板吗？我说，是的，爸爸。但它仍然很豪华。哦，天哪。我知道当我们不得不和移动厕所合影时，我们注定要成为朋友。我也是。好吧，听着，伙计们，我们会有更多的故事，因为就像我说的，这确实开启了我们生活中非常奢华的一部分。回顾我的旧照片和这些档案很有趣。我已经预留了更多故事要讲。哦，我等不及了。顺便说一句，每次你说“我翻阅了我的档案”，我不知道为什么。也许是因为我今天有点晕。我只是想象你就像《夺宝奇兵》的最后一幕，在你的车库里有所有这些箱子，你就像，哔，像一个小起重机一样。好吧，如果我能那么有条理就好了，那将是我梦想成真。哦，你会非常开心的。好吧，我们将休息一下，然后回来深入探讨《金钱》第二部分。好的，我们回来了。《金钱》第二部分。我们从帕姆在接待处非常疲惫的场景开始。她在打哈欠。吉姆在打哈欠。德怀特打着哈欠走进来。每个人都度过了一个艰难的夜晚。吉姆对德怀特说，我把它写下来了，因为它正好符合那个论点，即当人们试图对德怀特或安吉拉好时，几乎总是会适得其反。是的。吉姆非常友善地对德怀特说，你还好吗，对吧？德怀特说，我比你曾经好，
talking about it. We're like, the thing you need to see. The thing we're writing home about tonight is this toilet. I talked in great detail with my dad about that. And he was like, do you have a pedal you push? I'm like, yes, dad. But it's still fancy. Oh, my gosh. I knew we were meant to be friends when we had to take photos with the porta potty. Same. Well, listen, guys, we will have more stories coming up because like I said, this did kick off a very fancy part of our lives. And it's been fun to go through my old photos and these archives. And I've earmarked a few more stories to tell. Oh, I can't wait. By the way, every time you say I've gone through my archives, I don't know why. Maybe it's because I'm loopy today. I just picture you like in that final
或者将来会好。就是这样。就是这样。好的，德怀特。好的。是的。不仅如此，帕姆和吉姆刚住在德怀特的民宿里。这就是他们疲惫的原因。他们刚为他做了这件极其友善的事情。但没有，这在德怀特眼中没有为他们赢得任何好感。他仍然有尖刻的评论。但听着，他们不是唯一疲惫的人。安吉拉，迈克尔也因为做两份工作而非常疲惫。
scene of Raiders of the Lost Ark that somewhere in your garage you have all these boxes and you're like, beep, like a little mini crane going. Well, if only I could be that organized, it would be my dream come true. Oh, you would be so happy. All right, we will take a break and we will be back to dive in to Money Part 2. All right, we're back. Money Part 2. We're starting with the scene where a very tired Pam is at front reception. She's yawning. Jim is yawning. Dwight walks in yawning. Everyone's have had a rough night. And Jim says to Dwight, and I wrote this down because it just goes with that argument of when people try to be nice to Dwight or Angela, it almost always backfires on them. Yes. Jim very nicely says, you okay to Dwight, right? Dwight says, I am better than you have ever been
他非常非常困。他在错误的日子里非常困，因为现在瑞安出现了。哦，是的。他期待迈克尔做一个PowerPoint演示。很快就很清楚迈克尔根本没有准备，也不知道自己在做什么。瑞安质问他，这时我们发现，好吧，办公室里的人发现了，对吧，迈克尔有另一份工作。没错。瑞安告诉他，迈克尔，如果你的第二份工作影响了你在邓德·米夫林的工作，你就不能做。迈克尔对此回应，伙计们，这让我笑得太厉害了。他说，面对现实吧，反正我永远也学不会怎么做这个。
or ever will be. There you go. There you go. Okay, Dwight. Okay. Yeah. And not only that, Pam and Jim just stayed at Dwight's B&B. That's why they're tired. They've just done this incredibly nice thing for him. But no, it has gained them no favor in Dwight's eyes. He still has a snarky remark. But listen, they're not the only people who are tired. Angela Michael is also very tired from working two jobs.
是的。这太诚实了。这太真实了。我只是被这种诚实逗笑了。这太真实了。然后瑞安看向后排，他看到了达里尔。好吧，他听到凯利在笑，就像强迫性的笑，完全是为了让他看过去。是的。他说，达里尔在这里做什么？离开这个会议。达里尔说，好吧，很高兴离开。哦，是的。这个，我不需要在这里。凯利说，好的，我稍后再见。他说，我稍后有计划。他对她太诚实了。这让我笑得前仰后合。但我想要你知道他们那个吻。是的。如果你看到20分35秒，伙计们，我拍了一张照片。约翰·卡拉辛斯基完全破功了。
He's very, very sleepy. He's very sleepy on the wrong day because now Ryan has showed up. Oh, yeah. He's expecting Michael to do a PowerPoint presentation. It's really clear very quickly that Michael has not prepared at all and has no idea what he's doing. And Ryan confronts him, and this is when we find out, well, the bullpen finds out, right, that Michael has another job. That's right. And Ryan tells him, Michael, you cannot have a second job if it affects your work at Dunder Mifflin. And Michael responds to this, you guys, it made me laugh so hard. He says, let's face it, I was never going to learn how to do this anyway.
他做那种奇怪的鼓起脸颊的动作，当你破功并试图转过身时。他看着你，他快要崩溃了。好吧，安吉拉，如果你看，是你，然后是约翰，然后是我。嗯。这在会议室里是不应该被允许的。你不应该把我们三个排成一排。不。因为我有一种身体记忆，就是向前倾，越过约翰和你说话。
Yeah. Which is so honest. It's so true. I just laughed at the honesty. It's so true. And then Ryan looks to the back row and he sees Daryl. Well, he hears Kelly laughing, like forced laughter to totally get him to look over. Yes. And he says, what's Daryl doing here? Get out of this meeting. Daryl's like, fine, happy to leave. Oh, yeah. This, I don't need to be here for this. And Kelly's like, okay, I'll see you later. He's like, I have plans later. It's like so honest with her. It cracks me up. But I want you to know that smooch that they have. Yeah. If you go to 20 minutes, 35 seconds, you guys, I took a picture of it. John Krasinski is full on breaking.
哦，但我们三个也会。我转向另一边，因为我不能看你们。我知道。就像我把身体转开了。约翰在笑，而你看起来像是在崩溃的边缘。是的。不，我记得我们在整个场景中都乱成一团。我们乱成一团。
He's doing that weird puffy cheek thing when you break and you're trying to turn away. He's looking at you and he is losing it. Well, Angela, if you look, it is you, then John, then me. Mm-hmm. This should never be allowed in a conference. You should never seat the three of us in a line. No. Because I have a sense memory of leaning forward and talking to you over John.
但这个场景太精彩了。看完这个场景后，我给保罗发了短信，我说，保罗，这是完美。你知道，他为这个场景而战，这个整个“无论谁，无论什么”。是的。他为它而战。他喜欢它。我喜欢这个会议室场景的每一个节拍。太搞笑了，安吉拉。
Oh, but also the three of us would go. I'm turning the other way because I can't look at you guys. I know. Like I've positioned my body away. John is laughing and you are like, look like you're on the verge. Yeah. No, I remember we were a mess during this whole scene. We were a mess.
他有没有告诉你我给他发短信关于“无论谁，无论什么”？不，我甚至没有，我只是给他发短信说这是完美。我也做了同样的事。他告诉我，编剧室里有投票要剪掉它。他承受了很大的压力要剪掉那个梗。他真的觉得它应该保留。他真的很高兴他这么做了，因为那是我们那年被提名时，他们在演员工会奖上播放的片段。就是那个“无论谁，无论什么”的场景。
But this scene is so brilliant. After I watched the scene, I texted Paul, and I said, Paul, this is perfection. You know, he fought for this scene, this whole whomever, whoever. Yep. He fought for it. He loved it. And I love every beat of this conference room scene. It's so funny, Angela.
这有多酷？太棒了。它确实成为了那些小经典时刻之一。而且我也觉得我认识你，我一直这么说。但是《办公室》姐妹的粉丝们，你们和我们一样喜欢这个节目。我只是觉得这种场景在其他节目中从来没有被允许呼吸。它们会屈服于网络压力或其他什么。而这个我们谈论“无论谁”和“无论什么”的巨大长场景，在其他节目中是不会发生的。
Did he tell you that I texted him about whomever, whoever? No, I didn't even, I just texted him and told him it was perfection. I did the same thing. And he told me that there was like a vote in the writer's room to cut it. There was a lot of pressure on him to cut that runner. And he really felt like it should stay in. And he's really glad he did because that's the clip they ended up playing at the SAG Awards when we were nominated that year. It was the whoever, whom ever seen.
我相信这一点。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这个场景的邮件，人们想知道它是如何设法出现在这一集里的。我要给他们一个大大的赞。谢谢格蕾丝·H、阿利马·H和泰·欧文斯写信。关于“无论谁，无论什么”。好吧，我有一个记住何时使用“无论谁”或“无论什么”的好方法。是什么？我觉得这很简单。我要为你读一下。它在网上，你知道，所以你可以在世界上找到这个，但它一直对我很有帮助。准备好了吗？是的。“无论谁”（Whomever）是一个宾格代词，像代词“他”、“她”和“他们”一样工作。例如，把文件给部门里的“无论谁”。所以如果你在脑子里想，是“无论谁”（Whomever）还是“无论谁”（Whoever），你只需要在脑子里说，把文件给部门里的他，或者把文件给部门里的她。看？或者“无论谁”。或者“无论谁”。而“无论谁”（Whoever）是一个主格代词，像代词“他”、“她”和“他们”一样工作。例如，“无论谁”写了这首诗都应该获奖。你可以替换为，他写了这首诗并应该获奖。她写了这首诗并应该获奖。哦，你听到了吗？所以只要在脑子里把“无论谁”（Whomever）连接到他、她和他们，把“无论谁”（Whoever）连接到他、她和他们。我觉得这非常有帮助。我感觉有点“啊哈”，但我认为你知道是什么，我必须说这个一直让我困惑。啊哈，我只是积极地
How cool is that? It's so good. And it's become truly like one of the little classic moments. And also I just feel like I know you and I say this all the time. But Office Ladies fans, you love the show as much as we do. And I just feel like these kind of scenes were never allowed to breathe on other shows. They would succumb to network pressure or whatever. And this huge long scene where we talk about whomever and whoever, it just wouldn't have happened on another show.
避免不得不使用任何一个。好吧，我觉得那非常有帮助。我想知道你现在告诉我的会不会成为我的转折点。在今年剩下的时间里，你只会听到我用很多“无论谁”和“无论谁”，因为它终于在46年后点击了。就像我老师教我怎么拼写星期三的那一年，因为我一直拼错。她说，只要写“周三”（wednest day）。我说，周三。你知道我永远拼不出的词是什么吗？
I believe that. Well, we got a lot of mail about this scene, people wanting to know how it managed to be in the episode. I'm just going to give them a shout out. Thank you, Grace H, Alima H, and Ty Owens for writing it. about whoever, whomever. Well, I have a great way to remember which to use whoever or whomever. What is it? I think it's really simple. I'm going to read it for you. It's online, you know, so you can find this out there in the world, but it's what's always helped me. Ready? Yeah. Whomever is an object pronoun and works like the pronouns, him, her, and them. For example, give the document to whomever in the
这是一个真正的挑战，特别是当你成为新父母时，是“腹泻”（diarrhea）这个词。我正要说，是腹泻吗？是的，因为它是一个令人困惑的词。它非常难拼写。当你有了孩子时，你必须经常给你的妈妈朋友发短信。是的。你真的必须。作为新父母，腹泻经常出现。
department. So if you just are thinking in your head, is it whomever or whoever, you would just in your head say, give the document to him in the department, or give the document to her in the department. See? Or whomever. Or whomever. Whereas whoever is a subject pronoun and works like the pronouns, he, she, and they. For example, whoever wrote this poem should win a prize. You could substitute, he wrote this poem and should win a prize. She wrote this poem and should win a prize. oh do you hear it so just attach whomever to him her and them and attach whoever to he she and they in your head i thought that was really helpful i'm feeling a little bit of an uh-huh but i thought you know what it is i have to say this one has just always stumped me uh-huh and i just actively
我很难拼写它。还有，恶心（nausea）对我来说也可能有点困难。Nauseousia，nauseousness。N-A-U-S-E-A。我不知道。我不知道。但腹泻确实，你知道吗？这是一个棘手的词。
avoid having to use either well i thought that that That was very helpful. I'm wondering if what you've told me now is going to become the turning point for me. And for the rest of this year, you're just going to hear a lot of whomevers and whoever's for me because it will have finally clicked after 46 years. It's like the year my teacher told me how to spell Wednesday because I kept spelling it wrong. And she was like, just write wednest day. And I was like, wed nest day. You know what word I can't spell ever?
是的。有它，拼写它，都不好。好了。我们回到这一集吗？是的，我们也许应该。好的。迈克尔必须辞职。你知道，瑞安对他说了，你不能做两份工作。
And it's a real challenge, especially when you become a new parent, is the word diarrhea. I was going to say, is it diarrhea? Yeah, because it's a confusing word. It's very difficult to spell. And you have to text it a lot to your mom friends when you have a baby. Yeah. You really do. Diarrhea comes up a lot as a new parent.
它影响了这一份。所以迈克尔去找菲格罗先生辞职。这是一个很棒的场景。他选角太完美了。迈克尔对摄像组说，你们正在拍摄历史。是的。他，你知道，他不辞职。我喜欢菲格罗先生的反应。他说，你知道，在你走之前消毒你的耳机，随时欢迎回来。他几乎没有抬头。是的。好吧，而且，你知道，我做过电话推销员
And I have a hard time with it. Also, nausea can be a little bit difficult for me. Nauseousia, nauseousness. N-A-U-S-E-A. I don't know. I don't know. But diarrhea is really, you know? It's a tricky one.
我做这份工作时一定辞职并重新加入过三次。这是一个旋转门。他们不指望长久。任何在办公室待了一个多月的人都被认为是资深员工。哦，是的。实际上很难从那些地方被解雇。就像，你必须非常努力。这是真的。他和菲格罗先生卖的东西之一是Lipofedrin，一种减肥药？是的。我查过了。它不是真的，对吧？在美国不是。等等，什么？好的。我在奥地利发现了一个网站，说它在卖Lipophedrine。他们是以我们的剧集命名的吗？因为我不知道。我敢肯定，听着，我对此一无所知，但我确实在奥地利的一个网站上找到了它。伙计们，别吃那个，再次重申，我们这个节目的搜索历史
Yeah. Having it, spelling it, none of it's great. All right. Shall we get back to the episode? Yeah, we maybe should. All right. Michael has to quit the job. You know, Ryan has said to him, you cannot work two jobs.
安吉拉在奥地利网站上做什么？好的，好吧，回到办公室，安迪已经走到帕姆的桌子前，他真的想让帕姆把他和安吉拉撮合在一起，因为他的招数不管用。等等。关于这一点我有几件事要说。首先，在23分18秒，你会认为，女士们，如果我知道整个场景的一部分是有人在看我的屁股，我应该穿塑身衣而不是我的老奶奶内裤，因为在23分18秒，安迪在看我的屁股，我走过去，你看到了大大的内裤痕迹。听着，安吉，那是现实。那只是一个纪录片，那是一个纪录片，为什么我没有看剧本说，哦，是的，今天是他们拍摄安迪看我屁股的日子，他们会放大我的屁股，也许我不应该穿最差的内裤，洗衣日的内裤。让我告诉你一件事，我穿洗衣日
It's affecting this one. So Michael goes to Mr. Figuero to quit. This is such a great scene. He's so perfectly cast. Michael says to the camera crew, you are filming history. Yes. He doesn't, you know, he doesn't quit things. I love Mr. Figaro's response. He says, you know, sanitize your headset before you go and you're welcome back anytime. And he barely looks up. Yeah. Well, and, you know, I worked as a telemarketer
内裤每一天。好的，你知道为什么吗？因为它们该死的舒服，而且你知道我在我的一天中，当我试图成为一个老板女士并完成事情时，不需要什么吗？是丁字裤。我不需要丁字裤。我不需要一根内裤绳塞进我的屁股里。只是为了当我走来走去时，人们看不到我大腿上的一条线，让他们知道我，哦，天哪，今天穿了内裤。为什么女人总是必须掩盖我们穿内裤的事实？谁在乎你是否看到我们每天穿的内裤在我们屁股上留下的痕迹。惊喜。我显然站在你这边。我显然穿老奶奶内裤。我只是说如果我早知道我走过去的屁股镜头会被展示，也许，也许我会
and I must have quit and rejoined this job three times when I had it. It's a revolving door. They're not expecting like longevity. Anyone who had been in the office for more than a month was considered like a senior employee. Oh, yeah. It was actually very difficult to get fired from those places. Like, you would have had to try really hard. It's true. One of the things he's selling with Mr. Figaro is Lipofedrin, a diet pill? Yep. I looked it up. It's not real, right? Not in the U.S. Wait, what? Okay. I found a website in Austria that says it's selling lipophedrine. Did they name it after our episode because I don't I don't know I'm pretty sure listen I don't know anything about it but I did find it on a website in Austria don't take that guys again our search history for this show
那天选了另一条。不。我只是这么说。我为你内裤痕迹鼓掌。我觉得这很有老板风范，也很女权主义。女士们，自豪地展示你的内裤痕迹。因为你很舒服，你的屁股被遮住了，你的私处被遮住了，你正在完成事情。你知道那个内裤痕迹说明了什么吗？什么？我不在乎。那个内裤痕迹说明我有比你盯着我的屁股看更重要的事情要担心。这就是它说的。口袋和内裤痕迹是我所代表的。好了？所以，让我们继续前进，因为我们对此非常有热情，但安迪说安吉拉对他的招数没有反应。猜猜他的招数是什么？我知道。他月球漫步经过会计部10次。真想
what is Angela doing on an Austrian website okay well back in the office Andy has gone up to Pam's desk he really wants Pam to set him up with Angela because his moves are not working Hold up. I have a few things to say about this. First of all, at 23 minutes, 18 seconds, you would have thought, ladies, if I knew a whole bit of a scene was someone checking out my ass that I would have worn Spanx and not my granny panties because at 23 minutes 18 seconds, Andy's checking out my butt and I sashay by and you see big old panty lines. Listen, Ange, that's reality. that's just it's a documentary it's a documentary why didn't I look at the script and say oh yeah today's the day they shoot andy looking at my butt they're going to zoom in on my butt maybe I shouldn't have the bottom of the barrel undies the laundry day undies let me tell you something what I wear laundry day
看到那个。我知道。我希望我们有那个的B卷。我知道。好吧，有很多删减片段。安迪有一个完整的梗，非常有趣，关于他如何试图追求安吉拉。他实际上走到会计部，邀请她去初中参加一个JV长曲棍球锦标赛。那是一个有点有趣的场景。但他走到办公室里的每个人，不仅仅是帕姆，并向他们搭讪，而且他分享的内容有点不合适。我让萨姆剪了两个片段。萨姆，你能播放第一个吗？看，你们是我在这个办公室里最亲密的朋友。彼此彼此。因此我来找你们。说出你的事。我得了相思病。还有发情病。
undies every day all right you know why because they're effing comfortable and you know what I don't need in my day while I'm trying to be a boss lady and get things done is a wedgy. I don't need a wedge. I don't need a string of panty up my butt. Just so that when I am walking around, people don't see a line on my thigh that lets them know that I'm, oh, shocker, wearing underwear today. Why do women always have to disguise the fact that we wear underwear? Who cares if you see a line on our butt from our underwear that we're wearing every day. Surprise. eyes. I'm clearly on your side. I clearly wear granny panties. I'm just saying if I had known forever in time the shot of my ass walking by was going to be featured, maybe, maybe I would have
那是不可能的，除非你是说淋病。我说的是安吉拉。好的，所以他去找了吉姆和德怀特。他没有停在那里。现在菲利斯卷进来了。萨姆，你能播放那个吗？我全身都痒着安吉拉痘。哦，天哪，你确实得了淋病。
picked a different pair that day. No. That's all I'm saying. I applaud you for your panty line. I think it's boss lady of you and feminist of you. Ladies, display your panty line with pride. because you are comfortable, your butt is covered, your lady bits are covered, and you are getting shit done. You know what that panty line says? What? I don't give a shit. That panty line says I have more important things to worry about than your viewing of my ass as I walk by you. That's what it says. Pockets and panty lines are what I stand for. All right? So, moving us along because we're very passionate about this, but Andy says Angela's not responding to his moves. Guess what his moves are? I know. He moonwalked past accounting 10 times. What a love to
嘿，安迪。也许这是那种你只需要做了她，才能把她从你的系统中清除的情况。别插手，你。菲利斯！搞什么鬼，菲利斯？哦，天哪！我知道。
seen that. I know. I wish we had B-roll of that. I know. Well, there's a lot of deleted scenes. Andy has a whole runner that's very funny about how he's trying to court Angela. He actually goes over to accounting and invites her to a JV. LaCross tournament at the junior high. And that's kind of a funny scene. But then he goes around to everyone in the office, not just Pam, and hits them up and is kind of inappropriate with what he's sharing. And I had Sam pull two clips. Sam, will you play the first one? Look, you guys are my closest friends in this office. Right back at you. And as such I come to you. State your business. I am dying of love sickness. and horny sickness.
那都在删减片段里。DVD上这一集的删减片段非常棒。好吧，我不知道你是否注意到了，但我们有一些人写信进来。马特·C和杰西卡·埃尔南德斯说，当安迪向帕姆询问关于安吉拉的建议时，埃德·赫尔姆斯是被指导那样站的吗？
That is impossible, unless you mean gonorrhea. I'm talking about Angela. Okay, so he's gone to Jim and Dwight. He doesn't stop there. Now Phyllis gets involved. Sam, will you play that one? I am itching all over with Angela Pox. Oh my God, you do have gonorrhea.
你知道他们在说什么吗？哦，当他几乎做劈叉的时候？是的。是的。哦，太恶心了。不，伙计们，那只是埃德·赫尔姆斯。埃德只是做了那个选择，这让我笑得前仰后合，我破功了好几次，因为它非常有趣。
Hey, Andy. Maybe this is one of those situations where you just have to do her. to get her out of your system. Stay out of this, you. Phyllis! What the hell, Phyllis, S? Oh my gosh! I know.
嘿，安迪。也许这就是那种你必须和她在一起，才能把她从你脑子里赶走的情况。你别插手，菲利斯！搞什么鬼，菲利斯？天哪！我知道。
That's all in the deleted scenes. It's a really good batch deleted scenes for this episode on the DVD. Well, I don't know if you noticed, but we had some people write in. Matt C. and Jessica Hernandez says, when Andy is asking Pam for advice about Angela, was Ed Helms directed to stand like that?
那些都在删减片段里。这一集的DVD里有一批非常棒的删减片段。嗯，不知道你们有没有注意到，我们收到了一些观众来信。马特·C和杰西卡·埃尔南德斯问，当安迪向帕姆咨询关于安吉拉的建议时，艾德·赫尔姆斯是被要求那样站着的吗？
Do you know what they're talking about? Oh, when he does almost the splits? Yes. Yes. Oh, so gross. No, you guys, that was just Ed Helms. Ed just made that choice and it cracked me up and I broke several times because it was very funny.
你知道他们在说什么吗？哦，就是他差点劈叉的时候？对，对。哦，太恶心了。不，伙计们，那只是艾德·赫尔姆斯。艾德自己做了那个选择，这让我笑得不行，我好几次都笑场了，因为那真的太搞笑了。
He's just trying to get to like Pam's eye to eye level and it was a very, very funny choice. In the DVD commentary, Jen Salata and Paul Lieberstein talk about the fact that that Jen had written Andy very sweet, you know, like trying to court Angela. And then Paul wrote Andy just trying to get laid. And there's this like kind of mix. But they said it works. It works. It's like Andy can be really nice. But then he's also just such a tool sometimes. Yes. Well, I noticed something in this scene. At 23 minutes, 58 seconds, I'm calling it rope bracelet alert. Oh. Andy is wearing one of those nautical rope bracelets on his wrist. They were very popular in the 80s. I remember people wearing them. Do you remember that? Yeah. Well, I had to know more. So I did a tiny deep dive on these rope bracelets. And here's what I found out. What did you found out? It's called a Turkshead bracelet. It is a sailor's knot. And according to the website, Mystic knotwork, it is traditionally
他只是想让自己的视线和帕姆保持平齐，这是一个非常、非常有趣的表演选择。在DVD评论音轨中，珍·萨拉塔和保罗·利伯斯坦谈到，珍原本把安迪写得非常贴心，你知道，就像是在努力追求安吉拉。然后保罗写的安迪只是想找人上床。这中间有一种混合的感觉。但他们说这行得通。确实行得通。安迪有时可以表现得非常好，但有时他又真的很欠揍。是的。嗯，我在这一幕里注意到了一件事。在23分58秒，我称之为“绳编手链警报”。哦。安迪的手腕上戴着那种航海绳编手链。它们在80年代非常流行。我记得有人戴过。你记得吗？记得。嗯，我必须了解更多。所以我对这些绳编手链做了一次小小的深度挖掘。这就是我发现的。你发现了什么？它被称为“土耳其头”手链。这是一种水手结。根据“神秘结艺”网站的说法，它传统上
made of a single strand of cord that is then doubled up upon itself. And captains in Newport would often have their crew wear matching bracelets to help the dockmaster recognize them as they approached the dock. It's also said that sailors wore these bracelets so they could wipe sweat from their brow. And they sometimes made them as good luck gifts for their loved ones back home. But I thought it was such an appropriate choice for Andy since he is a sailor. for him to be wearing. But we don't really talk about it much. It's just been hinted at. I mean, it's going to come out much more in later seasons. But I thought this was a very well-placed detail.
由单股绳索制成，然后将其对折。纽波特港的船长们经常让船员佩戴配套的手链，以便码头管理员在他们靠近码头时能认出他们。还有一种说法是，水手们戴这些手链是为了擦掉额头上的汗水。他们有时也会把这些手链作为好运礼物送给家乡的亲人。但我认为这对安迪来说是一个非常合适的选择，因为他是个水手。他戴着它很合适。但我们并没有过多谈论它。这只是被暗示了一下。我的意思是，这在后面的几季中会更多地显露出来。但我认为这是一个放置得非常好的细节。
Yes. One of the things they talked about, I can't remember which DVD commentary it was, but Ed and Mike Scher talked about how much thought they put into Andy's look. Because he is sort of that East Coast prep school, go sailing, you know, kind of crowd, and that they really dressed him. His ties are different from the other guys and his accessories. He has that's Sailor's bracelet. Is that what you call it? Sailor's not. Sailor's not.
是的。他们谈论的事情之一，我不记得是哪一集的DVD评论了，但埃德和迈克·舒尔谈到了他们在安迪的造型上投入了多少心思。因为他属于那种东海岸预科学校、喜欢航海的那类人，他们确实精心打扮了他。他的领带和配饰都与其他男同事不同。他有那个“水手手链”。你是这么叫它的吗？水手结。水手结。
Yeah. So now Michael is going to approach Kevin because he needs money. And he's like, you know, he knows Kevin gambles and he's wondering if Kevin has like any end on a fixed fight. Michael basically describes a movie, right? Yes. He goes into way more detail about why someone would, like, throw a fight. And Kevin's like, no, I don't know anyone in the mob. So then he turns to Oscar and he's like, I need an advance.
是的。现在迈克尔要去找凯文，因为他需要钱。他说，你知道，他知道凯文赌博，他想知道凯文是否有什么内幕消息，比如假球之类的。迈克尔基本上是在描述一部电影，对吧？是的。他非常详细地描述了为什么有人会打假球。凯文说，不，我不认识黑帮的人。于是他转向奥斯卡，说，我需要预支工资。
But there's also a deleted scene that would have come here where he hits up Phyllis at the water cooler for money. And it's so awkward and cringy. Wow. It's in the deleted scenes. Well, this just starts this amazing back and forth with Oscar, where Oscar is going to start coaching. Michael are trying to help Michael with his finances. Oh, it's so good. They talked a little bit on the DVD commentary about what brought this whole dynamic up.
但这里还有一个被删减的片段，他会在饮水机旁向菲利斯要钱。那场面太尴尬、太让人脚趾扣地了。哇。它在删减片段里。嗯，这开启了与奥斯卡之间精彩的来回对话，奥斯卡开始指导迈克尔，或者说试图帮助迈克尔理财。哦，太棒了。他们在DVD评论中简要谈到了是什么引发了这种动态。
And Mike said that they were looking at characters that hadn't been utilized. They felt like they hadn't seen enough of Oscar. And they loved how Oscar was always so pragmatic and Michael's so irrational. And so they thought this would be a great time to utilize the character of Oscar. It's so good. It's really good. I loved that about our show, and that we had this deep bench of talent and that the writers would consider, oh, who could we pair up? Who haven't we heard from in a little while?
迈克说，他们当时在寻找那些还没被充分利用的角色。他们觉得奥斯卡的戏份还不够多。他们喜欢奥斯卡总是那么务实，而迈克尔总是那么不理智。所以他们认为这是利用奥斯卡这个角色的好时机。太棒了。真的很好。我喜欢我们剧集的这一点，我们拥有深厚的人才储备，编剧们会考虑，哦，我们可以把谁配对？我们有一段时间没听到谁的声音了？
Whose history or story should we bring to the front this week? It always ends up producing some of my favorite storylines. Me too. It's a very thoughtful way to approach writing, right? It's like they would look at the big picture of the show and the different chemistry of the characters. and dynamics, and I love Oscar and Michael. There's a lot more in the deleted scenes that didn't make it in, but it's just so fun to watch them.
这周我们应该把谁的历史或故事带到台前？这总是能产生一些我最喜欢的故事情节。我也是。这是一种非常深思熟虑的写作方式，对吧？就像他们会审视剧集的全局，以及角色之间的不同化学反应和动态，我喜欢奥斯卡和迈克尔。删减片段里还有很多没放进去的内容，但看他们互动真的很有趣。
Well, speaking of fun to watch, Kelly is going to go to Daryl's office and give him an ultimatum. Oh, God. She wants to know, what are your plans tonight? And he says, I'm spending the evening with my daughter. And then she's like, okay, fine, me or your daughter. And he's just really a matter of fact, is like, my daughter? Yeah. Well, we got a lot of mail about this scene, but it was an interesting thing.
说到看得很开心，凯莉要去找达里尔，给他下最后通牒。哦，天哪。她想知道，你今晚有什么计划？他说，我要和女儿共度夜晚。然后她说，好吧，选我还是选你女儿。他真的很务实，说，我女儿？是的。嗯，我们收到了很多关于这一幕的邮件，但这是一件有趣的事情。
Katie Bowman, Kelsey Cundiff, Sarah Ellis, and Brittany McMahon all said, in both Daryl's office and in Mr. Figuero's office, there is a flyer on the wall that says Terry's diner. Is this a real place in Scranton? Yes, it is. Did you look it up? Because I looked it up, because I noticed it too. I noticed it too. Also, it's a yellow flyer. So it's very like, it catches your eye. Well, first of all, the phone number on the flyer is correct. Oh, no. So, and still working today. Did you call it? I didn't call it, but I thought maybe we should call it today. Right now? I don't know. Okay. Why not? Sam, can you call Terry's Diner?
凯蒂·鲍曼、凯尔西·坎迪夫、莎拉·埃利斯和布列塔尼·麦克马洪都说，在达里尔的办公室和菲格罗先生的办公室里，墙上都有一张写着“特里餐馆”的传单。这是斯克兰顿真实存在的地方吗？是的，确实是。你查过吗？因为我也查了，因为我也注意到了。我也注意到了。而且，那是一张黄色的传单。所以它非常显眼，很吸引人。嗯，首先，传单上的电话号码是正确的。哦，不。而且至今仍在使用。你打了吗？我没打，但我当时想也许我们今天应该打一下。现在吗？我不知道。好吧。为什么不呢？萨姆，你能给特里餐馆打个电话吗？
Oh, my God. What are we going to say? We haven't talked about this at all. Maybe. Terry, may I help you? Hi. This is Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey from the TV show The Office. We're re-watching the show, and we noticed Terry's Diner Flyer in the episode The Money, and we just wanted to call and say hi. Hi.
哦，天哪。我们要说什么？我们根本没讨论过这个。也许。特里，有什么能帮您的吗？你好。我是电视节目《办公室》的珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛。我们正在重温这部剧，我们在《金钱》那一集中注意到了特里餐馆的传单，我们只是想打个电话问候一下。你好。
Did you guys know that your diaries? Do you really? Do people call? We have people that call from all over the world. Oh, my gosh. And what is your name? name. Desiree. Desiree. It's so nice to meet you. What do people say when they call you? Is this really a diner? Is this really Terry's? I'm watching the office. Oh my gosh. Desiree,
你们知道你们的传单吗？真的吗？有人打来吗？我们有来自世界各地的人打来电话。哦，天哪。请问您怎么称呼？名字。黛西蕾。黛西蕾。很高兴认识你。人们打电话时都说什么？这真的是一家餐馆吗？这真的是特里餐馆吗？我正在看《办公室》。哦，天哪。黛西蕾，
you're like old hat to this. Well, thank you so much, Desiree, for taking time to talk to us today. We don't want to keep you from your job. But what is the special today? Do you have a daily special? Our blue plate special for today is beer battered cod with a cup of soup, fries, slaw, and tartar sauce. That's our blue plate Then we have a few lunch specials and dinner specials Well, that sounds fantastic And Desiree, will you please tell everyone there We say hi
你对这些已经习以为常了。嗯，非常感谢你，黛西蕾，今天抽出时间跟我们聊天。我们不想耽误你的工作。但今天的特色菜是什么？你们有每日特色菜吗？我们今天的蓝盘特价是啤酒炸鳕鱼，配一碗汤、薯条、凉拌卷心菜和塔塔酱。这就是我们的蓝盘特价。然后我们还有一些午餐和晚餐特价。嗯，听起来太棒了。黛西蕾，请你告诉那里的每个人，我们向他们问好。
And I'm sorry, so many people call all the time We appreciate you guys being such like good sports Nope, that's fine, no problem Have a good rest of your day Have a good day, Desiree Okay, bye Bye Bye
抱歉，一直有这么多人打电话。我们很感激你们这么好说话。不，没关系，没问题。祝你余下的一天过得愉快。祝你今天愉快，黛西蕾。好的，再见。再见。再见。
Well, there you have it Oh my God, she was so lovely People call all the time From all over the world. All over the world. Oh, my gosh. Maybe our props department should have blacked out the phone number. Now I really want that blue plate special.
好了，就是这样。哦，天哪，她太可爱了。人们一直都在打电话。来自世界各地。世界各地。哦，天哪。也许我们的道具部门应该把电话号码涂掉。现在我真的很想吃那个蓝盘特价。
But, okay, back to the scene. Daryl has told Kelly, no, he chooses his daughter, right? She's ticked off. She leaves and she does like a W and an L and then like a knife across the neck, Jenna. Yeah. I looked up what this meant. It means whatever loser. die, right? That's a consensus. Yeah, I mean, Kelly, he's crossed her and she's going to leave and,
但是，好吧，回到剧情。达里尔告诉凯莉，不，他选择了他的女儿，对吧？她气坏了。她离开了，然后做了一个“W”和“L”的手势，接着是一个抹脖子的动作，珍娜。是的。我查了一下这是什么意思。意思是“输家”（Whatever Loser），去死，对吧？这是共识。是的，我的意思是，凯莉，他惹恼了她，她要离开，而且，
you know, with some drama. Well, back upstairs in the break room, everyone's kind of gossiping about Michael's money troubles. It's the gossip room today. Is it gossip in the break room? I think it's gossip in the break room today. Hot goss in the break room. Well, I don't know if you noticed, but there was some very careful staging. of people because Michael has to enter and not see Pam. So you're standing tucked in the corner and then in between you and Michael is Kevin. So Michael comes in as like talking about Jim and Pam's sex life. And then Kevin walks away, revealing Pam.
你知道，带着一些戏剧性。嗯，回到楼上的休息室，大家都在八卦迈克尔的财务问题。今天这里是八卦室。休息室里在八卦吗？我想今天休息室里全是八卦。休息室里的劲爆八卦。嗯，我不知道你有没有注意到，这里有一些非常精心的舞台调度。因为迈克尔进来时不能看到帕姆。所以你站在角落里，然后你和迈克尔之间是凯文。所以迈克尔进来时在谈论吉姆和帕姆的性生活。然后凯文走开了，露出了帕姆。
And lady, every time it happened and Steve would get that look of awareness in his eyes, it would make me laugh. You were going on her. It would make me laugh. It was so funny. And then Michael denies that he's having any money problems. And to prove it, he gets out a $1 bill and he just crumples it up and puts it in his pocket. Would you do that if you were having money problems, would you? And everyone calls him out on it.
天哪，每次发生这种情况，史蒂夫眼中流露出那种觉察的神情时，我都会笑出声。你当时在看她。这让我笑个不停。太搞笑了。然后迈克尔否认他有任何财务问题。为了证明这一点，他拿出一张1美元的钞票，把它揉成一团放进兜里。如果你有财务问题，你会这样做吗？你会吗？大家都拆穿了他。
They're like, wait, you just put it in your pocket. Well, guys, it was originally written in the script that Michael would rip up the dollar bill. But then we found out when we were filming that that's actually against the last. law. Yeah, you can't do that to money. Yeah, you can't. It's illegal to deface U.S. currency to the point at which it's rendered unusable. And by the way, we wouldn't have just done it once. We would have had to do multiple takes. We would have committed multiple crimes in shooting the scene if we had ripped up that dollar bill. Well, I actually think it's funnier that he crumples it up and puts it in his pocket. I think that's a funnier joke. I do too. I think that was a good
他们说，等等，你刚才把它放进兜里了。嗯，伙计们，剧本里原本写的是迈克尔会把那张美元撕碎。但后来我们在拍摄时发现，这实际上是违法的。法律。是的，你不能那样对待钱。是的，你不能。损毁美国货币到无法使用的程度是违法的。顺便说一句，我们不可能只拍一次。我们必须拍很多次。如果我们撕碎那张美元，我们在拍摄这一幕时就犯了多次罪。嗯，我其实觉得他把它揉成一团放进兜里更好笑。我觉得那是个更好笑的笑话。我也这么认为。我觉得那是个好
thing. After this break room, we have some fantastic Kelly and Daryl, some Carol. We got some Carol coming up. Yes, and Daryl has a classic line in the scene. Oh, I know exactly what you're talking about. All right. Say it. He says to Kelly, hey, I like you. What's not to like? But you need to access your uncrazy side. Access your uncrazy side went like viral. It's a good line. And then Kelly has this amazing talking head where she says, Daryl is the most complicated man she's ever met. I mean, who says exactly what they're thinking? What kind of game is that? Yeah.
主意。休息室这一幕之后，我们有一些精彩的凯莉和达里尔的戏份，还有一些卡罗尔。我们有卡罗尔要出场了。是的，达里尔在这一幕里有一句经典台词。哦，我知道你在说什么。好吧。说出来。他对凯莉说，嘿，我喜欢你。有什么不喜欢你的？但你需要展现你“不疯狂”的一面。展现你“不疯狂”的一面都火了。这是一句好台词。然后凯莉有一个精彩的单人访谈，她说，达里尔是她见过最复杂的男人。我的意思是，谁会直接说出心里话？那算什么游戏？是的。
What kind of game is he playing where he just tells me exactly how he feels? He just says the truth. What the hell? She can't believe it. Well, coming up, we have a little fun piece of trivia because we have Creed and Oscar in the kitchen with Michael. This sounds like a game of clue, right? It does. We have Creed and Oscar and Michael in the kitchen.
他到底在玩什么游戏，竟然直接告诉我他的真实感受？他只是说实话。搞什么鬼？她简直不敢相信。嗯，接下来，我们有一个有趣的小花絮，因为克里德和奥斯卡在厨房里和迈克尔在一起。这听起来像是一场“妙探寻凶”游戏，对吧？确实。克里德、奥斯卡和迈克尔在厨房里。
Yes, and Creed is offering Michael some financial advice. He talks about how he needs to file for bankruptcy. Yes, he says bankruptcy is nature's do-over. Thanks, Creed. And then Creed has a talking head where he explains that he just transfers his debt to William Charles Schneider. and he holds up a passport. And the passport says the birthday is February 8th, 1943. Now, February 8th is Creed's birthday.
是的，克里德正在给迈克尔提供一些财务建议。他谈到他需要申请破产。是的，他说破产是大自然的“重来一次”。谢谢你，克里德。然后克里德有一个单人访谈，他解释说他只是把债务转移给了威廉·查尔斯·施耐德。他举起了一本护照。护照上写着生日是1943年2月8日。现在，2月8日是克里德的生日。
So I caught that right away. Yeah, guys. William Charles Schneider is Creed Bratton's real legal name. That is his birthday. And he is holding up his actual real life passport. I just can imagine Creed being like, guys, I'll bring in my passport. And they're like, okay. Well, I texted Creed about it.
所以我立刻就发现了。是的，伙计们。威廉·查尔斯·施耐德是克里德·布拉顿真实的法定姓名。那是他的生日。而且他举着的是他现实生活中真实的护照。我简直无法想象克里德当时说，伙计们，我把我的护照带来。他们说，好吧。嗯，我给克里德发了短信问这件事。
And he did, in fact, bring in his real passport for this scene. Amazing. And he said that after the first take, Greg said, Crete, you might want to just cover up your passport number with your finger. Because that's a real legal document. Yes, Crete. So Crete did. Creed held it up in such a way that you could see some of the information, but not the rest. So amazing.
他确实为这一幕带来了他真实的护照。太神奇了。他说在第一次拍摄后，格雷格说，克里德，你可能想用手指遮住你的护照号码。因为那是真实的法律文件。是的，克里德。所以克里德照做了。克里德举起它的方式让你能看到一些信息，但看不到其余的。太神奇了。
Amazing. Well, I want to say also, Angela, in this kitchen scene, I notice another flyer. This time for Sal's pizza in Scranton. This is also a real place. We're not going to call it. But it was founded by two brothers, Sal and Nick Lupoli in Salem, New Hampshire. Their Scranton location is now closed. But I will tell you, they are the home of the famous 19-inch, three-pound pizza.
太神奇了。嗯，我还想说，安吉拉，在厨房这一幕里，我注意到了另一张传单。这次是斯克兰顿的萨尔披萨店。这也是一个真实的地方。我们不会打给它。但它是由萨尔和尼克·卢波利两兄弟在纽罕布什尔州的塞勒姆创立的。他们在斯克兰顿的分店现在已经关门了。但我可以告诉你，他们是著名的19英寸、3磅重披萨的发源地。
Dang. And you can still get it in New Hampshire, but the Scranton location is now closed. I have more pizza info for you. Oh, okay. Buckle in. Fan catch from Megan Smith. At 28 minutes, 26 seconds, you can see a flyer for City Slice Pizza. Okay.
天哪。你仍然可以在纽罕布什尔州买到它，但斯克兰顿的分店已经关门了。我还有更多披萨信息给你。哦，好吧。系好安全带。来自梅根·史密斯的粉丝发现。在28分26秒，你可以看到一张“城市切片披萨”的传单。好吧。
This is also a real pizza place in Scranton, and it is right near the University of Scranton campus. Megan would like you to know that she used to work there as a pizza delivery driver, and their buffalo chicken pizza is incredible. Lady, this got me wondering. Oh, God. I'm in. I'm in. What is the best pizza in Scranton? We talk about the pizza in Scranton on the show. We have flyers for pizza in Scranton on the show. I had to know. I feel like this is like when you go to the South and you ask someone where's the best barbecue. You will get like 10 incredibly passionate answers. You are correct. Okay. Let's hear it. According to Trip Advisor, the best pizza in Scranton is a little pizza heaven. Okay. According to Yelp, it's Marconi's Pizza House. And incidentally, Yelp rated A Little Pizza Heaven number two.
这也是斯克兰顿一家真实的披萨店，就在斯克兰顿大学校园附近。梅根想让你知道，她以前在那里做过披萨外送员，他们的水牛城辣鸡披萨简直绝了。天哪，这让我很好奇。哦，天哪。我加入。我加入。斯克兰顿最好的披萨是什么？我们在节目里谈论斯克兰顿的披萨。我们在节目里有斯克兰顿披萨的传单。我必须知道。我觉得这就像你去南方问别人哪里有最好的烧烤一样。你会得到10个非常热情的答案。你说得对。好吧。让我们听听。根据猫途鹰（TripAdvisor），斯克兰顿最好的披萨是“小披萨天堂”。好吧。根据Yelp，它是“马可尼披萨屋”。顺便说一句，Yelp把“小披萨天堂”排在第二位。
Alfredo's, which is featured on our show, was number three on Yelp and number four on TripAdvisor. But it is in the top five. But when I consulted two local blogs written by residents of Scranton, they both declared that the number one pizza in Scranton is Vincenzo's Pizza Pizza. Zaria. So there you have it. Okay. I think, Angela, when we go on our trip to Scranton, we should try all these pizzas and decide for ourselves. We should do that. We should also go to Poor Richards. And now we need to go to Terry's Diner, which is actually in Musick. Listen, we've got a whole like Pennsylvania tour ahead of us. We are going to eat our way through Pennsylvania, clearly. Okay? I can't wait. I can't wait either. This is going to be a fun trip. It really is. Okay. Well, I really need to talk about Michael's talking head that's coming up. Lady, before we leave the kitchen, I just have to say one more thing.
我们节目中出现的阿尔弗雷多披萨在Yelp上排名第三，在猫途鹰上排名第四。但它在前五名。但当我查阅了两位斯克兰顿居民写的当地博客时，他们都宣称斯克兰顿排名第一的披萨是文森佐披萨。扎里亚。所以就是这样。好吧。我想，安吉拉，当我们去斯克兰顿旅行时，我们应该尝试所有这些披萨，并自己做决定。我们应该那样做。我们还应该去“可怜的理查德”酒吧。现在我们需要去特里餐馆，它实际上在穆西克。听着，我们前面有一整个宾夕法尼亚州的巡回之旅。我们显然要一路吃遍宾夕法尼亚州。好吗？我等不及了。我也等不及了。这将是一次有趣的旅行。确实如此。好吧。我真的需要谈谈迈克尔接下来的单人访谈。天哪，在我们离开厨房之前，我必须再说一件事。
Okay. Why did Creed have a sugar dish positioned right in front of himself on the edge of the table during this entire scene? It's so odd. He does not have a cup of coffee or tea. He has no food. But for whatever reason, he has moved the sugar dish right in front of him. Check it out, everybody. Maybe he had a spot on his shirt and they didn't have time to change it.
好吧。为什么克里德在这一整幕中把一个糖罐放在桌子边缘他自己的正前方？太奇怪了。他没有咖啡或茶。他没有食物。但出于某种原因，他把糖罐移到了他正前方。大家去看看。也许他的衬衫上有个污点，他们没时间换了。
And they just are hiding it with the sugar dish. That's my, that's my theory. I wonder sometimes because Creed would make choices and scenes that were very random and very funny. And maybe there's some improv that happened that got cut out. I don't know. But it was very obvious to me that for some reason the sugar dish ended up there. It's a mystery. Yeah.
他们只是用糖罐把它挡住了。这是我的理论。我有时会想，因为克里德在场景中会做出非常随机且非常有趣的表演选择。也许有一些即兴发挥被剪掉了。我不知道。但对我来说很明显，出于某种原因，糖罐最终出现在了那里。这是一个谜。是的。
Okay. Let's talk about Michael's talking head because it's pretty amazing. Okay. Well, I have labeled this talking head, here's your damn spin-off. So Crete has told Michael that declaring bankruptcy is this do-over. It's like going in the witness protection program. Michael lights up like a Christmas tree. He has a talking head where he says he's always wanted to be in the witness protection program.
好吧。让我们谈谈迈克尔的单人访谈，因为它太精彩了。好吧。我给这个单人访谈贴上了标签：“这就是你该死的衍生剧”。所以克里德告诉迈克尔，申请破产是“重来一次”。这就像进入证人保护计划一样。迈克尔像圣诞树一样亮了起来。他有一个单人访谈，说他一直想参加证人保护计划。
He's even already picked out his other name, his other identity. Are you ready? He is Lord Rupert Everton. He is a shipping merchant who raises fancy dogs. I need to see it. There's your damn spinoff. Michael Scott pretending to be a shipping merchant who raises fancy dogs. It's a must see.
他甚至已经选好了他的另一个名字，他的另一个身份。准备好了吗？他是鲁珀特·埃弗顿勋爵。他是一位饲养名贵犬只的航运商人。我必须看到它。这就是你该死的衍生剧。迈克尔·斯科特假装成一个饲养名贵犬只的航运商人。这绝对必看。
I would watch that. And you know they would probably put him in Arizona, not near any water, but he's a shipping merchant raising fancy dogs. And he legally changes his name to Lord Rupert Everton. Peacock. Peacock. Are you listening? Peacock. This leads to one of the most famous moments on the office when Michael enters the bullpen and loudly declares bankruptcy.
我会看的。你知道他们可能会把他安排在亚利桑那州，离水很远的地方，但他是个养名贵狗的航运商人。而且他合法地把名字改成了鲁珀特·埃弗顿勋爵。孔雀。孔雀。你在听吗？孔雀。这引出了《办公室》中最著名的时刻之一，迈克尔走进办公区，大声宣布破产。
And Jenna, it was so hard not to laugh and I knew I couldn't laugh because I was standing on a stool at the supply closet. Yeah. They moved you over. I am right by him. Yes. Well, we had a question from. Hannah Yen, who had the idea for Michael to yell, I declare bankruptcy in the bullpen. Guys, this was a pitch from writer Lee Eisenberg.
珍娜，当时真的很难不笑，我知道我不能笑，因为我正站在储藏室的凳子上。是的。他们把你移过去了。我就在他旁边。是的。嗯，我们收到了汉娜·延的一个问题，是谁想出让迈克尔在办公区大喊“我宣布破产”这个主意的？伙计们，这是编剧李·艾森伯格提出的点子。
He told me that when he pitched the line, he actually performed it for Paul. And he'll never forget it. Well done. Well done, Lee Eisenberg. But yes, just classic line, so fun. And by the way, Steve did a little play on that for a New Year's message. where he declared Happy New Year. He did.
他告诉我，当他提出这句台词时，他实际上是为保罗表演了一遍。他永远不会忘记那一幕。干得好。干得好，李·艾森伯格。但确实，这句台词太经典了，太有趣了。顺便说一下，史蒂夫在新年致辞中还玩了这个梗，他宣布“新年快乐”。他确实这么做了。
Just warmed my heart. I know, me too. Well, you guys, I declare a break. I love it. Yes, I declare a break as well. We'll be back to break down the second half of this episode in just a moment. All right, we are back. Oscar and Michael are in the conference room and Oscar is going through all of Michael's financial records.
真是暖心。我知道，我也是。好了，各位，我宣布休息。我喜欢这个。是的，我也宣布休息。我们稍后回来继续解析这一集的后半部分。好了，我们回来了。奥斯卡和迈克尔在会议室里，奥斯卡正在检查迈克尔所有的财务记录。
We are really going to get some insight into where all of Michael's money is gone. Well, you know, Jenna, leading up to the scene, there was a deleted scene where Michael is begging Oscar to sort of go through his finances with him. And Oscar does not want to do it. He's like, no, I'm not going to do it. And Michael says, if you help me with this, I will pay you. $4,000 in coupons, credits, and backrubs, or I'll give you $5,000 cash. And Oscar's like, I'm starting to see how you got in this situation.
我们真的要深入了解迈克尔所有的钱都去哪了。嗯，你知道，珍娜，在这一幕之前，有一个被删减的片段，迈克尔恳求奥斯卡帮他梳理财务。奥斯卡不想做。他说，不，我不会做的。迈克尔说，如果你帮我，我会付给你4000美元的优惠券、积分和背部按摩，或者我给你5000美元现金。奥斯卡说，我开始明白你是怎么陷入这种境地的了。
It's interesting because at the beginning of money part one, it's sort of implied that Jan is the root of Michael's financial problems, that she's doing this renovation of the condo and she's spending a ton of money. She got a Porsche? They got a Porsche. But as we see in this scene, perhaps Michael has contributed to some of these problems. They certainly don't help each other out because in deleted scenes, Oscar also lists some of Jan's expenses. Oh, well, good.
这很有趣，因为在《金钱（上）》的开头，暗示简是迈克尔财务问题的根源，她在翻修公寓，花了一大笔钱。她买了保时捷？他们买了保时捷。但正如我们在这一幕中看到的，也许迈克尔也导致了其中一些问题。他们肯定没有互相帮助，因为在被删减的片段中，奥斯卡也列出了一些简的开销。哦，好吧，很好。
Yeah. Good. Because it did seem like she was a big part of this problem. Oh, she is. Well, in this scene, we find out that Michael spent $125 on the best of, the Muppet Show DVD. I looked it up on Amazon. I could not find this DVD. I don't know if anyone cares, but I looked it up. I couldn't find it. I found a lot of other box sets, but none of them were $125. I looked up the Core Blaster Extreme, so did I. Which Michael spent $1,200 on. Yes.
是的。很好。因为她看起来确实是这个问题的主要原因。哦，她确实是。嗯，在这一幕中，我们发现迈克尔花了125美元买了《布偶秀》精选DVD。我在亚马逊上查了一下。我没找到这张DVD。我不知道有没有人关心，但我查了。我没找到。我找到了很多其他的套装，但没有一个是125美元的。我查了“核心爆破极限”，我也查了。迈克尔花了1200美元买它。是的。
Could not find that either. I couldn't find it either, but you know what? It's so believable that this contraption would exist and that he would spend that money on it. Well, Michael says the Marine Corps uses this and it's where they got the core in their name is from the core blast extreme even though they don't spell it the same exactly Michael is having a very hard time grasping the gravity of this situation and ultimately Oscar encourages Michael to call jam yes he does not want her to know his money problems and Kevin by the way also agrees with him yeah let's keep our money problems away from the women like Kevin Kevin well meanwhile over an accounting Andy is about to give Angela a present yes Andy gives Angela this cat that he says he found by Vance refrigeration now we had a lot of people write in about
我也没找到。我也没找到，但你知道吗？这个装置确实存在，而且他会花那么多钱买它，这太可信了。嗯，迈克尔说海军陆战队用这个，他们名字里的“核心”就是来自“核心爆破极限”，尽管他们的拼写不完全一样。迈克尔很难理解这种情况的严重性，最终奥斯卡鼓励迈克尔给简打电话。是的，他不想让她知道他的财务问题，顺便说一下，凯文也同意他的看法。是的，让我们把财务问题瞒着女人们，像凯文那样。凯文，嗯，与此同时在会计部，安迪正要给安吉拉一份礼物。是的，安迪给了安吉拉这只猫，他说是在万斯制冷公司旁边发现的。嗯，我们有很多人写信来问
this and say that they believe this is the same cat that Dwight gave Angela garbage they believe it's garbage and you know what I stand corrected I think they're right I stand corrected as well we wondered about this a few episodes ago. Yes, this is totally meant to be garbage, which is now going to be renamed Bandit. That's right. Who you will eventually throw in the ceiling. We'll get there. Who will live in my drawer? So crazy. So yes, guys, thank you for writing in. You're right. We are watching this in real time, everyone. Yes. So we now agree with you. Here's something kind of interesting. If you watch the DVDs, the DVDs have like little screen savers, you know?
这件事，说他们认为这就是德怀特给安吉拉的那只猫“垃圾”，他们认为它就是“垃圾”。你知道吗，我收回前言，我想他们是对的。我也收回前言。我们几集前还在讨论这个问题。是的，这完全就是“垃圾”，现在要改名叫“强盗”了。没错。你最终会把它扔进天花板里。我们会讲到那里的。它会住在我的抽屉里？太疯狂了。所以是的，伙计们，谢谢你们写信来。你们是对的。大家，我们正在实时观看这一切。是的。所以我们现在同意你们的看法。这里有一件很有趣的事。如果你看DVD，DVD里有一些小屏保，你知道吗？
Mm-hmm. If you go to like commentary or deleted scenes or bonus features, there's little screen savers. For this episode, there's a very cute DVD screen saver of a little cat poking its head out of the box and meowing with Andy's dialogue. I'll put it up on Office Ladies' Pod. Now, what I don't know, Angela, is if we used the same cat actor, it looks very similar. And it seems just as sort of like weirdly, snugly and comfortable in your arms as it was in rains. Weirdly snugly comfortable. No, wanting to climb us like a tree and catapult off our head.
嗯。如果你进入评论、删减片段或花絮，会有一些小屏保。对于这一集，有一个非常可爱的DVD屏保，是一只小猫从盒子里探出头来，伴随着安迪的台词喵喵叫。我会把它发到《办公室女士》的播客上。现在，安吉拉，我不知道我们是否用了同一只猫演员，它看起来非常相似。而且它在你怀里似乎也同样奇怪地依偎着，很舒服，就像在雷恩怀里一样。奇怪地依偎着，很舒服。不，它不想像爬树一样爬我们，然后从我们头上弹射出去。
So I think it's the same cat because that cat wanted to leap through the air off of me, using me as a diving board. I think it was anticipating a future episode where it would be leaping. We would have to fly in the air. No, I guess what I'm saying is we set this up as some sort of feral cat, but it clearly is just fine being around humans. If it can crawl and jump off them. Yes, there you are. Well, listen, Dwight is clocking all of this interaction between Andy and Angela.
所以我认为这是同一只猫，因为那只猫想从我身上跳到空中，把我当成跳板。我想它是在预演未来的一集，它会跳跃。我们得飞到空中。不，我想说的是，我们把它设定为某种野猫，但它显然在人类身边很自在。如果它能爬上爬下的话。是的，就是这样。嗯，听着，德怀特正在记录安迪和安吉拉之间的所有互动。
He has to go out by the dumpster and play his recorder. He's so depressed. So depressed. He's playing, You Give Love a Bad Name by Bon Jo. I know. He's not in a good place. He's not in a good place. Jim and Pam notice, and they want to try to make him feel better, so they write their glowing review of Shrut Farms on TripAdvisor. Mm-hmm. The coveted TripAdvisor. He seems to like it. And Pam is really genuine. Pam's like, we really did enjoy our stay. She means it. She does. You know, again, the thing we've been pointing out that Pam is Dwight's best friend. Pam may not know that, but you can, see time and again where Dwight would see Pam coming through for him. Yeah. Michael has managed to get Jan on speakerphone and he's going to tell her about their money troubles. And she does exactly
他不得不走到垃圾桶旁吹他的竖笛。他太沮丧了。太沮丧了。他在吹邦乔维的《You Give Love a Bad Name》。我知道。他的状态不好。他的状态不好。吉姆和帕姆注意到了，他们想试着让他感觉好点，所以他们在猫途鹰上写了一篇关于施鲁特农场的精彩评论。嗯。令人垂涎的猫途鹰。他似乎很喜欢。帕姆真的很真诚。帕姆说，我们真的很享受我们的住宿。她是认真的。她确实是。你知道，再次强调我们一直指出的，帕姆是德怀特最好的朋友。帕姆可能不知道这一点，但你可以一次又一次地看到德怀特看到帕姆在支持他。是的。迈克尔设法让简接听了免提电话，他要告诉她他们的财务困境。她做的正是
what he feared. She's like, how could you? Yeah. She's disappointed in him and she's judging him and he can't take it. He runs away. What's interesting in this scene is there is sort of a whip pan to the window and you see this train going by outside, and then it whips back into the scene. Well, I want people to know that the actual window in the conference room where Oscar and Michael are having their scene, that's a window to nothing. That's a window to a painted screen. Right. On the other side of the painted screen was our craft service table with our snacks. Yes. They're in a warehouse. So they did one of those little magical cuts here where they went up to Paul Lieberstein's office and they whipped to the window and out Paul Lieberstein's writing office, there really was a train yard. And there really were
他所担心的。她说，你怎么能这样？是的。她对他感到失望，她在评判他，他受不了了。他跑开了。这一幕有趣的是，镜头有一个类似鞭扫的动作转向窗户，你看到外面有一列火车经过，然后又扫回场景。嗯，我想让大家知道，奥斯卡和迈克尔所在的会议室里的那扇窗户，那是一扇通往虚无的窗户。那是一扇通往彩绘屏幕的窗户。对。在彩绘屏幕的另一边是我们的餐点服务台，放着我们的零食。是的。他们在仓库里。所以他们在这里做了一个小小的魔法剪辑，他们去了保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室，然后扫向窗户，在保罗·利伯斯坦的写作办公室外面，真的有一个火车场。而且真的有
trains that went by. Yes. And what they had to do was they would cut in the middle of that whip such that you couldn't tell. And they inserted that little shot of the train going by because that did not actually happen in the scene because it was impossible. That is absolutely true. Every day we drove to work down Sattacoi, we passed a gunnery, we passed a crematorium, and we passed a working train like treks and a junkyard and a junkyard dog. All of that was right there. And all of that was out Paul Lieberstein's window.
火车经过。是的。他们必须做的是，在那个扫镜的中间进行剪辑，这样你就看不出来了。他们插入了那个火车经过的小镜头，因为在场景中并没有真正发生，因为那是不可能的。这绝对是真的。每天我们开车去上班经过萨塔科伊，我们经过一个炮兵训练场，经过一个火葬场，经过一条还在运行的火车轨道，还有一个垃圾场和一只垃圾场狗。所有这些就在那里。所有这些都在保罗·利伯斯坦的窗外。
A room with a view. And it was like just a freight train. There was not a passenger train. You know what I love about this is that the view. from the writer's rooms was actually like woven into this episode. And I just kind of love that. I used to say that if we were ever confronted with an actual zombie apocalypse in real life while working on the office, we'd be in a great position because we could head over to the gunnery, arm ourselves, and then hop the train. Yes. It just felt like, you know, a good spot to be in.
一间有风景的房间。那就像是一列货运火车。不是客运列车。你知道我喜欢这一点的是，编剧室的风景实际上被编织进了这一集。我真的很喜欢这一点。我过去常说，如果我们在《办公室》工作时真的遇到了现实生活中的僵尸末日，我们会处于一个很好的位置，因为我们可以前往炮兵训练场，武装自己，然后跳上火车。是的。这感觉就像，你知道，一个好地方。
should zombies suddenly overrun the world? Listen, I know there's no zombies in it, but I'm pretty sure John Wick would agree. He'd have his gunnery. He'd have some transportation. Jenna, I finally watched all the John Wick movies like you told me to. You watched all of them? What are you talking about?
如果僵尸突然占领了世界？听着，我知道里面没有僵尸，但我很确定约翰·威克会同意的。他会有他的炮兵训练场。他会有一些交通工具。珍娜，我终于看了你让我看的所有《疾速追杀》电影。你看了所有电影？你在说什么？
You told me to go watch them all. You said you have to see the John Wick movies. What are you talking about? What are you talking about? I said watch Keanu Reeves. movies like no you told me like speed and the matrix hold up lady you told me to watch the john wick movie you said you sam sam no i sam sam guys for taking this to court you did very excitedly this has come up multiple times you told me to watch john wick how good the movies are how attractive
你让我去看完它们。你说你必须看《疾速追杀》电影。你在说什么？你在说什么？我说的是看基努·里维斯的电影，比如《生死时速》和《黑客帝国》，别闹了，女士，你让我看《疾速追杀》电影。你说你……山姆，山姆，伙计们，为了这件事我们要上法庭。你非常兴奋地说了，这已经出现过好几次了，你让我看《疾速追杀》，说电影有多好，他有多迷人
he is in the movies lady how many are there there are three i did a marathon of them Okay, here's the thing. I spoke passionately about my love of Keanu Reeves movies, how they were getting me through the pandemic. I watched the first half of the first John Wick movie, but we couldn't finish it all in one night. Now, listen, I loved it. Look at my face right now.
他在电影里，女士，一共有几部？有三部。我马拉松式地看完了它们。好吧，事情是这样的。我热情地谈论了我对基努·里维斯电影的热爱，它们是如何帮我度过疫情的。我看了第一部《疾速追杀》的前半部分，但我们没法在一个晚上看完。现在，听着，我很喜欢它。看看我现在的脸。
I loved the coins. I loved how he had his coffee cups on a little towel next to his coffee machine. And Lee and I started doing that because we were inspired by what we saw in the John Wick movie. but we didn't finish it. Shut the front door. Because, you know, we rented it and then the rental ran out. Shut the front door. You gave me this whole call to action, which, by the way, now that I know you haven't even finished the first one,
我喜欢那些硬币。我喜欢他把咖啡杯放在咖啡机旁的小毛巾上。李和我开始那样做了，因为我们受到了在《疾速追杀》电影中看到的启发。但我们没看完。闭嘴。因为，你知道，我们租了它，然后租期到了。闭嘴。你给了我整个行动号召，顺便说一下，现在我知道你甚至没看完第一部，
now it makes sense to me why you went on and on about that towel by his coffee mug, because you never see that again. That's like five seconds. And then it's nothing but ass kicking for three movies. Listen, there's no more coffee mug. His whole house burns down. they blow his fucking house up
现在我明白为什么你一直喋喋不休地谈论他咖啡杯旁的那条毛巾了，因为你再也没见过那个场景。那只有五秒钟。然后接下来的三部电影全是打斗。听着，没有咖啡杯了。他的整个房子都被烧毁了。他们炸毁了他该死的房子。
so now it makes sense to me and I said I watched it with Josh I was like Josh we have to watch John Wick Jenna said we have to watch it and then I'm looking for the coffee pot and I'm like why is she talking so much about this coffee pot now it makes sense you've only seen like 20 minutes of the movie
所以现在我明白了，我说我和乔什一起看了，我说乔什，我们必须看《疾速追杀》，珍娜说我们必须看，然后我在找咖啡壶，我在想，为什么她一直在谈论这个咖啡壶？现在我明白了，你只看了电影的20分钟。
I saw the whole first half here's where I ended he's been really injured after a big fight at that weird club where all the you know assassin constantly goes to a rave A gazillion assassins always are at a rave. Yes.
我看了整个前半部分，这是我结束的地方：他在那个奇怪的俱乐部里经历了一场大战后受了重伤，所有那些，你知道，刺客总是去狂欢派对。一堆刺客总是在狂欢派对上。是的。
And he gets really wounded. And then that doctor, like, shoots him up with adrenaline. And he should definitely be resting. And he's about to go out and do more ass kicking. And I was tired and I was worried for him. You know, I told you I don't like it when people who have injuries continue to injure themselves. I needed a break. Well, then you might as well not watch the rest.
他受了重伤。然后那个医生给他注射了肾上腺素。他绝对应该休息。但他正要出去做更多的打斗。我很累，我很担心他。你知道我告诉过你，我不喜欢受伤的人继续伤害自己。我需要休息。嗯，那你最好别看剩下的部分了。
Because he literally gets stitched up and then people punch him in his stitches. No! And also, he is running. He is limping through like Rome or somewhere. Rome. How does he get to Rome? Second movie, second movie. And I literally turned to Josh and I said, you know what I can't handle right now?
因为他被缝合后，人们又打他的伤口。不！而且，他正在跑。他一瘸一拐地穿过罗马还是什么地方。罗马。他是怎么去罗马的？第二部电影，第二部电影。我真的转向乔什说，你知道我现在受不了什么吗？
Is if he gets hit by another car. And literally, three seconds after I said that, a car runs over him and sends him flying in the air. Sorry, that was a really long tangent for us, guys. But mouth agape. I am now the John Wick expert? How the hell did that happen? Well, I feel like I should watch them. Well, I think you should.
就是如果他再被车撞。就在我说了那句话三秒后，一辆车撞倒了他，把他撞飞到空中。抱歉，伙计们，这对我们来说是一个很长的题外话。但我目瞪口呆。我现在是《疾速追杀》专家了？这到底是怎么发生的？嗯，我觉得我应该看看它们。嗯，我想你应该看。
I think I will. But get ready because there's a lot of wound on wound. I don't like seeing wound on wound. Well, it's hard for me. Okay, I don't know. Where are we? Well, here we are. Angela walks over to Andy.
我想我会的。但做好准备，因为有很多伤口上的伤口。我不喜欢看到伤口上的伤口。嗯，这对我来说很难。好吧，我不知道。我们在哪？嗯，我们在这。安吉拉走向安迪。
She's holding the crazy cat. And she says, you may ask me out to dinner. Yes. She says, nothing fancy or foreign, no bars, no patios, no vegetables, and no seafood. What's up with no vegetables? I don't know. She's a vegetarian. What does she eat? Are you going to eat? What rice? Pasta? What will you eat? My cauliflower spaghetti? That's a vegetable. I know.
她抱着那只疯狂的猫。她说，你可以约我出去吃晚饭。是的。她说，不要太花哨或太异国情调，不要去酒吧，不要去露台，不要吃蔬菜，也不要吃海鲜。不吃蔬菜是怎么回事？我不知道。她是素食主义者。她吃什么？你要吃什么？米饭？意大利面？你会吃什么？我的花椰菜意大利面？那是蔬菜。我知道。
cauliflower spaghetti. Hold the cauliflower. She's not going to make it easy on Andy for sure. Well, Dwight is crushed. He runs to his stairwell. This is where he goes to pump himself up. or maybe where he goes to deal with sad feelings. This is his, I guess, little spot. This is his emotional nook. Yeah. And Jim follows him. He tries to comfort him. And it's really sweet because he kind of talks about his relationship with Pam and his own heartbreak. Listen, you know, I watched this episode three times. And the first time I watched it, I was like, oh, that's so sweet of Jim. He's giving Dwight a pep talk. Okay. By the third. third time I watched it. I was like, some flippin pep talk. I mean, this would like depress the
花椰菜意大利面。别放花椰菜。她肯定不会让安迪好过的。嗯，德怀特崩溃了。他跑向楼梯间。这是他去振作起来的地方，或者也许是他去处理悲伤情绪的地方。这是他的，我想，小地方。这是他的情感角落。是的。吉姆跟着他。他试图安慰他。这真的很甜，因为他谈到了他和帕姆的关系以及他自己的心碎。听着，你知道，我看了这一集三次。第一次看的时候，我想，哦，吉姆对德怀特太好了。他在给德怀特打气。好吧。第三次看的时候，我想，这算什么打气？我的意思是，这会让人
hell out of me. Like, is this the speech you say? This is what he said. I mean, she was with Roy, right? Talking about Pam. And then he says, and I quote, I just couldn't take it. I mean, I lost it, Dwight. I couldn't sleep. I couldn't concentrate on anything. Even weird stuff like food had no taste. So my solution was to move away. It was awful. It was something that I wouldn't wish on my worst enemy. Peptock? But Jim and Pam are together now. So is the rest of that scene that he's sort of saying, like, listen, I've been where you are,
沮丧透顶。就像，这是你说的演讲吗？这就是他说的。我的意思是，她当时和罗伊在一起，对吧？谈论帕姆。然后他说，我引用一下，“我简直受不了了。我的意思是，我崩溃了，德怀特。我睡不着觉。我无法集中精力做任何事。甚至像食物这样奇怪的东西也尝不出味道。所以我的解决办法是搬走。太可怕了。那是我不会希望发生在我最坏的敌人身上的事。”打气？但吉姆和帕姆现在在一起了。所以那一幕剩下的部分，他是在说，就像，听着，我经历过你现在的处境，
but look where I am now. It's going to be okay. He just doesn't say that part. He doesn't say any of that. Yeah. He literally says, I wouldn't wish it on my worst enemy, and that includes you. And then he leaves. Well, he has to go kiss Pam.
但看看我现在在哪里。一切都会好起来的。他只是没说那部分。他根本没说那些。是的。他确实说，“我不会希望发生在我最坏的敌人身上，那也包括你。”然后他就走了。嗯，他得去亲吻帕姆。
He has to go fall in love with Italian food. Yeah, he loves. Italian food. I'm just saying, Jim, you're like speech to make him feel better. You only delivered half of it. Yes. True. You needed the second half where it was like, buddy, look at me. I'm on the other side of it. I made it. We made it. You guys have a shot. Don't give up. Yes, that part is missing. Sorry, I'm still hot and bothered about John Wick. So taking it out on Jim. I mean, I'm very sorry. Did you enjoy the films when you watched them at least? You watched all three if you didn't like the first one, I can't imagine you would have watched two more just because I said.
他得去爱上意大利食物。是的，他喜欢意大利食物。我只是说，吉姆，你为了让他感觉好点而做的演讲，你只说了一半。是的。真的。你需要后半部分，就像是，伙计，看看我。我已经走出来了。我做到了。我们做到了。你们有机会。不要放弃。是的，那部分缺失了。抱歉，我还在为《疾速追杀》感到激动。所以把气撒在吉姆身上。我的意思是，我很抱歉。你至少在看电影时喜欢它们吗？如果你不喜欢第一部，你看了三部，我无法想象你会因为我说了什么而再看两部。
Lady, I would not half-ass watch something my friend told me to watch. Oh, well, I never finished Game of Thrones. I know. I couldn't do it. Okay, let's not salt in the wound. I'm sorry. I made you watch all of the John Wicks and I never finished Game of Thrones. Well, I'm going to watch the fourth one now because now John Wick is pissed.
女士，我可不会敷衍了事地看朋友推荐给我的东西。哦，好吧，我从来没看完《权力的游戏》。我知道。我看不下去。好吧，我们别在伤口上撒盐了。抱歉。我让你看了所有的《疾速追杀》，但我自己却没看完《权力的游戏》。好吧，我现在要去看第四部了，因为约翰·威克现在被惹毛了。
Now he is? Oh, he's super pissed now. He seemed like he had a lot of reasons to be pissed after the first 45 minutes of the first film. Oh, yeah. Well, there's that. Well, he's got more ass to kick. And now he's going to be doing it with Lawrence Fishburn. Oh.
他现在才被惹毛？哦，他现在超级火大。在第一部电影的前45分钟之后，他看起来已经有很多理由火大了。哦，是的。嗯，确实如此。好吧，他还有更多人要教训。而且现在他要和劳伦斯·菲什伯恩一起干了。哦。
Yeah. That's very interesting. Okay. Where are we? Well, Jan has arrived. Oh, God. Oh, it's so good. Because Michael has run off.
是的。那太有趣了。好吧。我们现在在哪？嗯，简到了。哦，天哪。哦，这太棒了。因为迈克尔跑掉了。
Oh, I will laugh so hard when she got out of the car and threw her keys at Oscar and hits him in the gut. Yeah. And when she throws her keys at Oscar at 38 minutes, seven seconds, you will see in the deep background, Kelly and Daryl leaning on Daryl's truck talking. Now, is that where the deleted scene would have gone? Were they talking by the dumpster? No, they weren't. So the deleted scene does happen in the warehouse, and it would have happened around this time. But Kelly walks up to Daryl and says, hey, I made you an apology mixed CD. Oh. An apology mix. And Daryl says, that's a lot of Michelle Branch.
哦，当她下车把钥匙扔向奥斯卡并砸中他的肚子时，我会笑得很大声。是的。当她在38分7秒把钥匙扔向奥斯卡时，你会看到背景深处，凯利和达里尔靠在达里尔的卡车旁聊天。那么，那是删减片段原本应该出现的地方吗？他们是在垃圾桶旁边聊天吗？不，他们不是。所以删减片段确实发生在仓库里，而且应该发生在这个时间点左右。但凯利走到达里尔身边说，嘿，我给你做了一张道歉混音CD。哦。一张道歉混音带。达里尔说，米歇尔·布兰奇的歌也太多了。
I'm never going to listen to these songs ever. And Kelly is kind of being flirty. She thinks they've made up. And Daryl is like, listen, this doesn't fix things. So do you think the two of them standing by the dumpster is post-deleted scene or pre-deleted scene? It feels like it's post. I feel like it's post. I feel like they just decided to leave it more to chance.
我永远都不会听这些歌。凯利表现得有点调情。她以为他们和好了。而达里尔却说，听着，这解决不了问题。所以你觉得他们俩站在垃圾桶旁边是在删减片段之后还是之前？感觉像是之后。我觉得是之后。我觉得他们只是决定让事情顺其自然。
Right? Sure. Well, Jan manages to find Michael. He is sitting on a train car. And she tells him, listen, I'm here for you. No matter what you're going through, you were there for me, I'm there for you. It's kind of a sweet scene in their own way. It really is. And she's hilarious in it. She's like, listen, you were there for me when even my own family wasn't there for me. They're still not talking to me under the advice of counsel. Like, what is Jan's family dynamic? Well, we had some fan questions from Catalina Rizzy, Haley McCoy, Sophia Spear, and Kate Walquist. They were all curious, where was Michael's train scene shot? Well, I'll tell you, it was not shot in the train yard by our set. It wasn't shot across the street? It was not.
对吧？当然。嗯，简设法找到了迈克尔。他正坐在火车车厢上。她告诉他，听着，我支持你。无论你经历了什么，你曾经支持过我，现在我也支持你。以他们的方式来看，这真是一个甜蜜的场景。确实如此。而且她在里面表现得太搞笑了。她说，听着，当连我自己的家人都不支持我的时候，你支持了我。他们现在还在律师的建议下不跟我说话。等等，简的家庭关系到底是怎么回事？嗯，我们收到了一些粉丝的问题，来自卡塔琳娜·里齐、海莉·麦考伊、索菲亚·斯皮尔和凯特·沃尔奎斯特。她们都很好奇，迈克尔的火车场景是在哪里拍摄的？嗯，我告诉你们，它不是在我们片场的火车场拍的。不是在街对面拍的吗？不是。
Wouldn't that have been convenient? It would have. but instead they drove all the way to Fillmore, California, and they shot it at the Fillmore Western Railway. It's a little bit of info from Kentapedia. Thank you, Kentapedia. Back in the office, Dwight comes back to his desk. It looks like he has a new resolve, doesn't it?
那不是会很方便吗？确实会。但他们反而一路开车去了加利福尼亚州的菲尔莫尔，在菲尔莫尔西部铁路拍摄的。这是来自“肯塔百科”的一点信息。谢谢你，肯塔百科。回到办公室，德怀特回到了他的办公桌前。他看起来有了新的决心，不是吗？
He kind of sits down, and he gets on the phone. He's being assertive making a call. He looks at Jim's desk and sees the pile of paper, grabs the ruler, starts shoving them back over, and Jim and Pam have this moment of like, well, Dwight's back. Yes. I have a little background catch I want to point out. Oh, me too.
他坐下来，开始打电话。他打电话时显得很果断。他看着吉姆的桌子，看到了那堆文件，拿起尺子，开始把它们推回去，吉姆和帕姆有了一种“好吧，德怀特回来了”的感觉。是的。我有一个小小的背景发现想指出。哦，我也是。
You go first. At 35 minutes, five seconds, we'll toggle back in time here, guys. There are no messy papers on Jim's desk when Angela is holding the squirrely cat. Yep. There's no messy papers. And then at 40 minutes, 37 seconds, when Dwight is about to shove everything aside, there are tons of papers. Tons. Jim did so much work in that 10 minutes. And was messy about it. Very messy. Well, at 40 minutes, 32 seconds, piled up in front of Jim and Dwight's desks, there are a ton of boxes. Yes. And they are from Boise Cascade. And I just want to let you know that my dad worked for Boise Cascade in St. Louis, Missouri, when I was a little girl. And he used to sometimes take me to work with him. And it was so
你先说。在35分5秒，我们把时间调回去，伙计们。当安吉拉抱着那只松鼠猫时，吉姆的桌子上并没有乱七八糟的文件。是的。没有乱七八糟的文件。然后在40分37秒，当德怀特准备把所有东西推开时，那里有成堆的文件。成堆的。吉姆在那10分钟里做了这么多工作。而且还弄得很乱。非常乱。嗯，在40分32秒，堆在吉姆和德怀特桌子前面的，有成堆的箱子。是的。它们来自博伊西卡斯卡德公司。我只想让你们知道，我小时候，我爸爸在密苏里州圣路易斯的博伊西卡斯卡德工作。他过去有时会带我去上班。那真是
fun and we would eat in the cafeteria and I would sit on the floor of his office and I would do coloring pages. But Boise Cascade, I was like, oh my gosh. And by the way, as a kid, we had tons of paper with the Boise Cascade watermark on it because they sold paper. Was that just a coincidence, Jenna, that this company, it had nothing to do with you. It just happened to be there. Total coincidence, but I remember being on set and noticing this set decoration and then talking to those guys all about how my dad worked for that company. And it was sort of a fun thing then when my family would see the episodes. Yeah.
太有趣了，我们会在食堂吃饭，我会坐在他办公室的地板上涂色。但是博伊西卡斯卡德，我当时就想，天哪。顺便说一句，小时候，我们有很多带有博伊西卡斯卡德水印的纸，因为他们卖纸。那只是巧合吗，珍娜，这家公司和你没关系。它只是刚好在那里。完全是巧合，但我记得在片场注意到这个布景装饰，然后和那些家伙聊起我爸爸曾在那个公司工作。所以当我的家人看到这些剧集时，那真是一件有趣的事情。是的。
And I'd be like, oh my gosh, Dad's Company, Boise Cascade. Oh, that's so cute. I never knew that. Yeah. Well, our final scene is this really sweet moment of Michael and Jan. They're walking off and Michael's saying, don't give back your implants. And she's like, I won't. I know you love them.
我会说，天哪，爸爸的公司，博伊西卡斯卡德。哦，那太可爱了。我从来不知道。是的。嗯，我们的最后一个场景是迈克尔和简之间非常甜蜜的时刻。他们走开了，迈克尔说，别把你的植入物取出来。她说，我不会的。我知道你喜欢它们。
And then they kind of have this back and forth. That was all improvised. Amazing. They are so great together. They're so great together. What great acting partners, Malora and Steve. Yes. It is such a blessing when you get paired with someone who you have that kind of chemistry with. They did such a good job casting this show. Allison Jones is just amazing and we were all so lucky. So incredibly lucky. We say it all the time. We still feel lucky now. And we're just so thankful for you guys that listen in every week. We love this community. Jen, I just want to take a quick personal moment. You know, this is our first episode back,
然后他们进行了一番你来我往的对话。那全是即兴发挥的。太棒了。他们在一起真是太好了。他们在一起真是太好了。马洛拉和史蒂夫真是很棒的表演搭档。是的。当你和有那种化学反应的人搭档时，真是一种福气。他们选角选得太好了。艾莉森·琼斯真是太棒了，我们都很幸运。真是太幸运了。我们一直这么说。我们现在仍然感到幸运。我们非常感谢每周收听的你们。我们热爱这个社区。珍，我想占用一点个人时间。你知道，这是我们假期后
recording since before the holidays. And my family and I got sick over the holidays. We had COVID and it was a scary time. You know, the Office Ladies fans were so, so supportive and kind and wrote me messages. The Facebook Office Ladies account did a whole video, and I watched it. My mom watched it. My husband and kids watched it. It was very moving for us to see this wonderful community. And it meant so much to me.
录制的第一集。我和我的家人在假期里生病了。我们得了新冠，那是一段可怕的时光。你知道，《办公室》的粉丝们非常非常支持和友善，给我写了信息。Facebook的“办公室女士”账号做了一个完整的视频，我看了。我妈妈看了。我丈夫和孩子们也看了。看到这个美好的社区，我们非常感动。这对我很重要。
I will never forget it. Angela, you shared that video with me. I cried because you're my best friend, and I know what that experience was like for you. And these loving messages, just the sweetest things. It's just saying like, lady, get better and sending pictures of hummingbirds to try to cheer you up. It's like, you know, it felt like a group of friends. Yes, it did. Reaching out, sending you just well wishes.
我永远不会忘记。安吉拉，你把那个视频分享给了我。我哭了，因为你是我的好朋友，我知道那段经历对你来说是什么样的。这些充满爱的信息，真是最贴心的东西。就像是说，女士，快好起来，还发蜂鸟的照片来试图让你振作起来。就像，你知道，感觉就像一群朋友。是的，确实。伸出援手，送上美好的祝愿。
And I have to say that the intimacy of this community is really real for us too. And yeah, thanks for being there for my friend, you guys. Well, we will be here next week. We have a really special episode. Someone were so thrilled to talk to. Randall Einhorn, our cinematographer and director from the office is going to be our special guest and we are going to revisit everything we missed and deep dive with Randall. We'll see you guys then. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was
我必须说，这个社区的亲密感对我们来说也是非常真实的。是的，谢谢你们一直支持我的朋友。好吧，我们下周会再见。我们有一集非常特别的节目。我们非常激动能采访到某个人。兰德尔·艾因霍恩，我们《办公室》的摄影指导和导演将成为我们的特别嘉宾，我们将重温我们错过的一切，并与兰德尔深入探讨。我们到时候见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集
initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie, Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。